Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen liebe guten Morgen Tim.
Freude trendet gerade und der Trump sagt, er hat jetzt den Virus.
Ich sage dir ganz ehrlich, zu früh gefreut. Ich glaube, die haben kein Wort. Melania, Trump soll der nämlich auch noch angesteckt haben, ne. Melanie, Trump macht Social Distancing von Donald Trump lange, lange bevor es jemals cool war. Ich sage dir das Ganze, stimmt nicht.
Buchletzpolitik Nummer dreihundertzweiundsechzig. Vom zweiten Oktober zwanzig zwanzig und es gibt wieder so viel Verschwörungstheorie-Potenzial neu auf der Welt, wo sollte man sonst reinschalten als zur Clearingstelle Hochnetzpolitik.
Ganz kurz meine Verschwörungstheorien, ja? Also, die eine Trump hat das Virus nicht.
Er braucht nur eine gute Ausrede, um diesen Streit um diese bescheuerten Debatten nicht weiterzuführen zu müssen. Das heißt, er wird nicht äh kann den Debatten ausweichen, ist aber jetzt jeden Tag immer in den Nachrichten, weil alle sich darum kümmern, wie gesund er ist,
er ist halt gesund, weil er gesund ist, kann dann nach vierzehn Tagen.
Durch eine Wunderheilung mithilfe von Bleiche, Chloro, Hydroxiklok Queen oder UV-Licht intravenös wie ein Phönix aus der Asche aufsteigen und sagen, oder irgendein Impfstoff, ja,
und sagen hier, ich bin geheilt, wählt mich. Ne, das ist einfach zu passend. Das ist die eine Verschwörungstheorie. Die andere Verschwörungstheorie ist.
Trump überlebt, aber beiden nicht und dann haben wir ähm oder beide überleben nicht und dann hätten wir auf jeden Fall am Start, weil.
Problem ist, Joe Biden wurde vor zwei, drei Tagen,
anderthalb Stunden aus nächster Nähe von dem Typen angeschrien, ja? Und so wie der Trump schreit, da glaube ich, da würde ich auch auf zwei Meter Abstand gehen müssen, ne? Und also ich halte das für hui ui ui, aber Schadensfreude äh verbietet sich ja, darf man nicht machen, darf man nicht machen,
Wir müssen jetzt alle Mitleid haben mit Donald Trump.
Einen Scheiß werde ich,
aber wahrscheinlich ist es ja auch so, die letzten Verschwörungstheorie sind alle viel zu kompliziert, es ist einfach das naheliegendste. Es ist einfach eine dumme Nuss und hat sich schön hier in den Virusschwall gestellt und ich hoffe, dass er diese ganze
Familie jetzt auch angesteckt ist. Wobei das einzige Bedrohungspat des Potenzial dabei ist natürlich so was, wenn er halt irgendwie genetisch äh.
Wenn er das überlebt, das ist das Problem. Die Gefahr ist, was, wenn er es überlebt?
So und dafür ist mir die Wahrscheinlichkeit einfach viel zu groß, dass er es überlebt, als dass ich jetzt hier irgendwie eine positive Nachricht sehen würde,
der steht dann einfach nachher da und sagt, guck, seht mich an, ich bin ein ähm vierundsiebzigjähriger Fettsack und ich hab's überlebt mit äh Hilfe von Trump ähm.
Ja, es betrifft fast niemand.
Joghurt oder so.
Keine Angst, es wird schon noch alles eine Weile äh immer schlimmer werden, bevor es wieder besser wird. Aber die goldenen Zwanziger, ich sage dir, die kommen noch, die kommen noch, die kommen.
Das könnte das also es gibt einen Silberstreif an Hoffnung, ja.
Jeden Fall auf jeden Fall wäre das der Plot Twist. Ich mein, man muss, muss ja auch sagen, aller guten Dinge sind drei, ne? Also Johnson Bolsonaro.
Der dritte.
Zu mir.
Bisher hat uns Trump immer enttäuscht, also von daher habe ich da keine Hoffnung.
Nee, also ich glaube, Verschwörungstheorie eins wird sein. Und äh dann.
Wird er äh es es hat er hat auch nur durch durch nichts.
Auch durch jeden Rückschlag hat er bisher noch keine äh noch irgendwelchen nennenswerten Schaden genommen. Ich meine, dass jetzt klar ist, dass der Typ seit Jahrzehnten ohne Einkommen ist,
ähm Steuer oder ein Steuerbetrüger beides jetzt nicht unbedingt die höchst angesehenen ähm Positionen, in der sich ein Präsident befinden kann, ja. Die Amerikaner diskutieren auch darüber, da natürlich mit seinen vierhundert
Millionen Dollar Schulden ähm.
Ohne Einkommen ist auch immer blöd, ne, welchen welchen Hebel noch andere gegenüber ihm haben könnten, ja? Ähm.
Da wird er auch noch gewinnen, ja, weil ich meine, wer, wer, ganz ehrlich, jemand, der keine Steuern zahlt, genießt genießt großen Respekt erstmal, ne?
Wir sind doch eigentlich hilflos. Wir wissen's auch nicht, wie es ist. Gib's doch zu. Das weiß ich nicht. Na ja, aber wie es genau ist, wir wissen nicht, wie es genau ist, ne, alles. Wir durchblicken das gesamte System doch nicht vollständig.
Entschuldigung, das ist das Sendungskonzept, das wir so tun. Warum fährst du da jetzt äh.
Ich wollte nur eine Brücke bauen, weil äh
wenn man nicht mehr weiter weiß, ne, gründet man einen Arbeitskreis oder man holt sich einen Experten rein für sonstige dystopische Fragen und äh haben wir nämlich auch und wir begrüßen an unserer äh Leitung, nämlich den Patrick, Patrick, Preyer, hallo,
Patrick.
Hallo und moin.
Herzlich willkommen bei Lokbuch Netzpolitik. Ähm hat ein bisschen länger gedauert, als wir das selber äh gedacht haben, aber wir haben keine gute Erklärung dafür.
Ja, wer,
Was lange währt, wird endlich gut. Ähm du, ich würde die ganz kurz versuchen, dich vorzustellen. Äh Tim hat ja gerade schon gesagt, wenn man nicht mehr weiter weiß, gründet man einen Arbeitskreis. Das war äh vor mehr als zehn Jahren, ne? Äh der AK Vorrat.
Schon lange her sein.
Kampf gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung äh damit in Deutschland mit einem sehr langen Atem sehr ähm erfolgreich gewesen bis heute im Prinzip. Du hast in äh Jura promoviert, warst kurze Zeit auch Richter, ne?
Ja, ich bin in Schleswig-Holstein Richter und im Moment äh roht das ähm wegen meines Abgeordnetenmandats, aber danach geht das wieder weiter. Das ist Zivilrichterstelle.
Aha und dann Gründungsmitglied, Piratenpartei?
Ja zweitausendsechs haben sich in Deutschland die Piraten gegründet und ähm mich hatte echt frustriert, wie unzuverlässig die anderen Parteien, die ja auch.
Für Bürgerrechte einzutreten.
Erscheinen, dann aber doch sind, wenn sie an der Regierung beteiligt sind, ne, also das war schon krass, als die Grünen mit an der Bundesregierung mit Schröder dran waren oder wenn die FDP dabei ist, dann ähm wie die ihre Grundsätze.
Über Bord werfen und einfach völlig andere Prioritäten haben.
Und die Piratenpartei hat halt versprochen, dass es unser zentrales Thema, die Menschenrechte im digitalen Zeitalter.
Und ähm deswegen habe ich war ich da gleich in der Seabase bei der Gründungsversammlung mit dabei.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, sie weiß, dass die Gründungsversammlung in der Seaways war, ich war nicht dabei, aber ähm da da warst du tatsächlich an diesem folgenschweren Tag äh sogar direkt noch mit anwesend.
Ja, da wurde viel diskutiert über die erste Satzung. Ich glaube, die ist sogar einiges kennt, noch im Netz irgendwo und das ist super, dass sie da schon alles findest von freiem Wissen über ähm Bürgerrechte, ähm
war schon ein sehr gutes Grundsatzprogramm drin.
Und vor allem, was sich ja von äh anderen Politikern der Piratenpartei unterscheidet ähm du bist ja noch dabei.
Ja, also ich wüsste auch nicht, äh wo man sonst wirklich ethisch vertretbar hier äh politisch aktiv sein könnte. Und die Piratenpartei gibt einem natürlich auch viel viel Freiraum auch
man auch sagen, ne? Also bestimmte Missstände,
in den anderen Parteien gibt, dass man sich hoch dienen muss, ähm dass nur irgendwie so Partei, Soldaten äh was werten können, die lange dabei gewesen sind,
die gelten ja nicht,
Und nur deswegen haben sie ja Leute auch wie äh Marina Weißband zum Beispiel ähm zur politischen Geschäftsführerin gebracht, die völlig spontan einfach mal, weil sich niemand gemeldet hatte, kandidiert hat damals
und da kann man natürlich tolle Leute wirklich in die Politik bringen.
Und ich glaube auch die, die jetzt bei anderen Parteien sind, sind ja immer noch gute Leute und es war gut, dass es die Piratenpartei gab, um die in die Politik zu holen.
Das war glaube ich auch eine ganz wichtige Funktion vom Arbeitskreis Vorratsdatenspeicherung, denn viele die sich da engagiert haben gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
sind später auch in Parteien aktiv geworden.
Ohne das zu sehr vertiefen zu wollen, aber es vielleicht an der Stelle auch nochmal.
Ganz ähm sinnvoll so, wie siehst du
Jetzt sozusagen diesen Weg der Piratenpartei, ich meine es war viel Hype am Anfang, sehr viel Streit dazwischen, dann viel Explosion, die ja auch noch lange angehalten hat, bis
jetzt auch noch zuletzt mit Julia Reha mit äh entsprechenden Auseinandersetzungen. Du hast jetzt sozusagen da die Stellung,
gehalten? Was würdest du meinen ist so die Ist-Realität derzeit dieses Projekts?
Ja, die Piratenpartei ist ja eine internationale Bewegung schon immer gewesen. In Schweden wurde sie zuerst gegründet.
Und in allen Ländern ähm gab es da immer so Auf und Abwellen, ne. Also wie gesagt, in Schweden war die Unterstützung am Anfang ganz groß. Äh dann kam so Deutschland,
in Island sind die Piraten bis heute in Kübay vierzehn Prozent, wenn fast mal eine Regierung beteiligt gewesen.
In Tschechien sind sie inzwischen die zweitstärkste Kraft sogar, also könnten auch an der nächsten Regierung beteiligt sein. Ich habe hier,
drei Piratenabgeordnete aus Tschechien mit im Europaparlament noch, sodass wir hier zu viert arbeiten können. In Luxemburg haben wir Piraten in der Nationalversammlung, aber das ist immer so ein so ein Auf und Ab, ne? Und deswegen ähm,
Kann man, glaube ich, nicht sagen, dass wir eine etablierte Kraft sind und in Deutschland speziell, glaube ich,
auch sehr viel an den Gesichtern, ne? Wenn man also dann äh ein Sprachrohr hast jetzt, wie Marina Weißband oder Katharina oder Julia Reeder
die bringen halt unsere Ideen auch total super und überzeugend auch in Medien rüber. Und wenn du das nicht hast, ähm dann äh hast du Schwierigkeiten äh wahrgenommen zu werden.
Ich hatte ja ein bisschen den, also was du grade als unbestreitbaren Vorteil mit ja auch drei sehr guten Beispielen benannt hast, eben dass dort,
Menschen auch, ja, in Anführungszeichen aus dem Nichts Chancen hatten.
Auch ein bisschen als eines der Probleme der deutschen Piratenpartei gesehen, dass es eben dann auch viele Leute, die Ost, die vielleicht auch besser im Nichts geblieben wären
ebenfalls versucht haben, solche Chancen zu ergreifen. Na, ich hatte das eigentlich mal so ein bisschen gespeichert unter das diese Partei
bisschen auch durch die Medien kaputtgespielt wurde in Deutschland. Also so da wurde einfach immer schön geguckt, dass man.
Irgendjemanden mal eben ein ein Mikrofon unter die Nase hält, ne? Es gab ja dieses Blog Popcornpiraten, was die ganzen ja Quatsch.
Diskussionen um die Partei auch immer gesammelt hat und ähm ich hatte eh also die Kehrseite schien mir ein bisschen zu sein, dass,
irgendwie ist nicht gelungen einen wirksamen Idiotenfilter.
Zu haben und dich dann jetzt im weiteren Verlauf sehe, ne, wenn dann eben nur die geblieben sind, die denen es eben immer einfach um die saubere, politische Arbeit ginge, wo ich dich eben auf jeden Fall äh zuzähle. Du scheinst das ja auch einfach vollständig durch ignoriert.
Zu haben. Das hast du ja geschafft, ja? Ich
Kann mich an keinen Piratenskandal erinnern, an dem, der irgendwo in deiner Nähe war, während du schön äh in Schleswig-Holstein im Landtag sitzt, jetzt in, im Europaparlament und immer einfach eine zielgerichtete politische Arbeit gemacht hast?
Ja, also es gab schon auch mal einen Skandal, ich weiß nicht, ob du das mitgekriegt hast, ähm.
Im Landtag ähm bin ich irgendwie an Informationen gekommen über Gefahrengebiete, die ausgewiesen wurden, das heißt Verdachtsdose Kontrollen durchgeführt werden konnten,
dann diese Informationen veröffentlicht und ähm
stellte sich heraus, dass die zwar geschwärzt waren vom Ministerium, was mir das was mir diese Anordnung ganz offiziell gegeben hatte
aber dass diese Schwerzung äh so dilettantisch gemacht war in den PDF Dateien, dass man dahinter sehen konnte und
Kernamen von Polizeibeamten und so weiter und ähm das war natürlich ein Fehler oder ich hätte es auch auch bemerken müssen oder sollen, dass das so dilettantisch gemacht war
aber ähm hat dann zur Rücktrittsforderung geführt, die Gewerkschaft der Polizei hat Strafanzeige erstattet, ne. Also da hast du schon äh stehst du unter enormen Druck.
Und das kann jedem passieren, auch wenn er wirklich versucht gute.
Ja gut, aber dir sind die Dokumente ja so gegeben worden, oder?
Genau, ich habe die so vom Innenministerium bekommen, habe gesehen, die haben Namen geschwert, sie haben die Namen geschwärzt und dachte dann natürlich, okay, ja super, dann äh jetzt raus damit,
das war gerade auf der politischen Agenda
aber man hätte sicherlich bemerken können, dass das so dilettantisch gemacht ist, dass die Namen von Polizeibeamten da da noch.
Ja gut, aber ich mein, das ist aber doch für für Pirat.
Piratenskanal ist das noch.
Ist das verglichen. Also fällt das bei mir noch nicht mal unter unter Skandal.
Irgendjemand einen Fingernagel abgerissen bekommen oder so, ne? Ja, okay, natürlich ist ein Fehler, okay, dann dann genau, dann sehen wir, wo deine.
Du hast also einen ganz normalen.
Äh oder einen sauber tarierten Maßstab-Wohnfehler anfängt und wo ein Skandal anfängt, den hatten vielleicht andere in der Piratenpartei äh an anderen Stellen tariert. Mit der hätte es auch gar nicht so weit drauf. Eigentlich wollte man sagen, dass man äh,
wollte betonen, dass du eben da,
schon einfach immer die inhaltliche Arbeit gemacht hast und wie ich dachte eigentlich als du im äh Landtag warst äh in Schleswig-Holstein, dass du da dann nicht noch nebenbei als Richter.
Auch noch gearbeitet hast.
Nee, du, das ist auch unvereinbar miteinander, also da gilt die Gewaltenteilung bei uns, ähm sondern dass das äh ruht, genauso wenn du Beamter bist zum Beispiel, dann ruht das während du im Parlament.
Aber dann halt das Privileg, dass nach dem Ende des Mandats du zurückhalten kannst in deinem Job, was du jetzt in der Privatwirtschaft nicht so hättest oder
nicht so einfach, ne? Und ähm das gibt dir natürlich eine gewisse Absicherung, aber halt auch eine Unabhängigkeit und deswegen,
konnte ich vielleicht in dem einen oder anderen Punkt da auch ähm ja konsequenter sein, weil ich einfach nicht jetzt finanziell drauf angewiesen bin, wiedergewählt zu werden. Und ich glaube, dieser.
Diese Wiederwahlgeschichte, die ist ein ganz große Wurzel von vielen Übeln in der Politik, weil Politiker sich sehr verbiegen, um wieder gewählt zu werden, schon allein aus finanziellen Gründen. Ja, es ist ja irre, wie hoch die Diäten sind,
grade gemessen an dem, was sie vorher meistens verdient haben. Und wende dich an so einen hohen Lebensstandard äh äh gewöhnt hast, einmal, dann machst du irre viel, um den zu halten und,
wieder aufgestellt zu werden von deiner Partei und das führt halt echt begünstigt auch dieses System, dieses.
Starre ähm Parteiensystem, dieses hierarchische, verkrustete
System, dass Leute an ihren Stühlen kleben bleiben. Und wenn du eine gewisse Unabhängigkeit hast, hast du das nicht. Das war übrigens auch bei Julia Reeder so, die ja schon,
vor irgendwelchen Skandalen einfach entschieden hatte. Ähm sie will nicht wieder antreten, weil sie keine Berufspolitikerin werden will. Ne, das ist ja eine super Einstellung.
Jetzt.
Weiß ich nicht genau, wieso das Berufsfeld oder Berufsbild in ähm im Europaparlament ist oder im Schleswig-Holsteiner Landtag, wenn man sich das
es gibt doch irgendwie, zumindest im Bundestag, gibt's doch solche, dass das hauptsächlich Juristen sind.
Wo man dann sagen will, okay, da ist das Argument, dass die vielleicht äh in diesem Bereich nochmal verdienen, äh nicht ganz so so treffend, aber dann auch Lehrerinnen und Lehrer haben wir viele, ne?
Beamte.
Ja, also du siehst daran, dass die ähm ja, die Juristen, die halt mit Gesetzen eh zu tun haben und die Lehrer, die quasi abgesichert sind von ihrer Stelle her,
die auf jeden Fall überrepräsentiert sind und das, denke ich, gilt wahrscheinlich ähnlich für
für Schleswig-Holstein und das geht auch ähnlich äh für das Europäische Parlament. Einfach weil die ähm durch ihren Job da quasi abgesichert sind. Aber es ist halt dann keine wirkliche Abbildung der Gesellschaft mehr und
man sieht ja in allen Wahlen, was für Probleme, wir haben viele Leute überhaupt noch für Politik zu interessieren,
glaube ich daran, dass die Menschen halt nicht mehr das Vertrauen haben, dass sie ähm Politiker wirklich in ihrem Interesse, also der Bevölkerung Politik
machen und nicht Eigeninteressen verfolgen oder halt Wirtschaftsinteressen, dass das Geld regiert. Und ich muss sagen, da haben die Leute halt auch recht vielfach, weil,
in der Politik und gerade in Europa, wo es ja so viele.
Lobbyisten in Brüssel gibt, wie sonst in keiner Hauptstadt in Europa. Ähm da ist halt echt die Politik dominiert von wirtschaftlichen Interessen. Die haben da enorm viel Einfluss,
dieses Herr an Lobbyisten was bezahlt wird, mit Seitenwechseln, das sozusagen Lobbyisten platziert werden in Regierungsjobs, zum Beispiel ist der aktuelle,
Digitalkommissar der EU, Herr war früher ähm ja Chef eines französischen IT-Konzerns.
Jetzt ist natürlich, also in diesem gesamten Themenbereich äh Interessenkonflikte und Einkommen ist ja die.
Also die vorgetragene Argumentation ist ja ungefähr so, die Diäten müssen so hoch sein, damit die.
Vertreterin nicht anfällig sind dafür finanzielle Sorgen zu haben und käuflich zu werden,
Ja, also dass du sagst, was ist das jetzt irgendwie acht, neuntausend Euro plus nochmal ungefähr genauso viel äh steuerfreie Pauschale, ne?
Ja, ich hab's jetzt noch gar nicht genau zusammengezählt, aber das kann ungefähr hinkommen, denn wir bekommen ja außer die, der Diät noch ähm diese Tagungsgelder, wenn wir,
in in Brüssel vor Ort sind. Die sollen die Unterkunftskosten abdecken, aber sind im Endeffekt so üppig und reichhaltig, dass da eigentlich alle noch dran verdienen, ne?
Also insofern ist es schon sehr hoch die Diät. Und natürlich ist diese Unabhängigkeit wichtig, aber erstens.
Wer so gierig ist, dass er da sich noch irgendwie bestechen lässt oder meistens ist es ja eher in Form von Nebentätigkeiten, ja
halte Vorträge und so weiter. Die Leute werden das machen, egal wie hoch ihre Diät ist. Ja, wenn die sich nebenher was verdienen können, dann machen sie das trotzdem. Und zweitens
Ich bin eher ein Anhänger der Theorie, der sagt, ähm.
Dass die Abgeordnete, die ja Vertreter des Volkes sein sollen, dass die halt auch ungefähr so viel verdienen sollten, wie die Bürger im Schnitt verdienen. Denn wenn du so viel verdienst, im Moment ist es ja mehr als das Doppelte, was die Abgeordne,
verdienen, ne, von dem Durchschnitt. Wenn du so viel verdienst, wie eigentlich nur ein Prozent der Bevölkerung, das hatte ich damals mal ausgerechnet, dann kannst du halt überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen, was für Sorgen die die normalen Bürger äh noch
haben. Also kannst du es nicht in eurem eigenen Leib äh verstehen, weil das viel zu weit weg ist von dir. Und ich glaube, das führt zu einer Interessenverschiebung.
Wäre mal ganz lustig, das mal so am Bruttosozialprodukt äh festzumachen. Geht's der geht's der Gesellschaft gut? Kriegst du auch mehr Gehalt?
Gab's ja schon immer mal wieder so Ideen, das zu machen, ne, aber und dann äh noch ein der zweite Punkt, den du anspaßt.
Wird der gesagt, okay, wir wir wollen gerne auch.
Sachkompetenz bei den Leuten haben, ne. Also was weiß ich, ne, irgendwie ein Kommissar, der war jetzt früher bei der äh bei dem bei einem Unternehmen, das auch in dem Bereich ist oder äh auch sehr häufig, ne, ein.
Minister oder eine Ministerin verlässt, äh die Politik und arbeitet dann in dem Bereich,
für den sie vorher zuständig war oder ein Kanzler. Äh berät weiter bei den Deals, die eher politisch äh vorangetrieben hat. Ähm.
Wird natürlich umgekehrt gesagt so, ja, du willst ja schließlich auch kompetente Leute dort haben, ne?
Genau, also Sachkompetenz ist sehr wichtig und gerade im Bereich Digitales haben wir halt das Problem, dass ganz viele von den Abgeordneten sich damit gar nicht auskennen und deswegen halt auch nicht verstehen, was die,
gefahren sind, was die Grenzen sind von digitaler Technik.
Und was damit für ein Missbrauch getrieben werden kann. Deswegen ist natürlich gut, wenn's Leute gibt, die ihr Geschäft verstehen, aber wenn es halt Leute sind, die kommerzielle Interessen verfolgt haben, ihr Leben lang wie Herr Breuton, dann brauchst du halt mindestens eine Karenzzeit,
Ne, das heißt, dann muss halt eine gewisse Zeit dazwischen gelegen haben,
um sicherzustellen, dass er nicht jetzt sozusagen für sein ehemaliges Unternehmen hier Politik macht und dann danach wieder dahin zurückkehrt und dann da eine Goldnase sich verdient. Und das hat halt hier totale gefehlt. Es gibt,
keinerlei Karenzzeit, der ist direkt aus der Wirtschaft in die Politik gewechselt und genauso umgekehrt, die Fälle, die du beschrieben hast, wo,
Politiker direkt in die Wirtschaft wechseln. Das wird halt deswegen gemacht, weil man quasi ihr Adressbuch äh kauft und ihre Kontakte und ihre Netzwerke,
Ne, die rufen dann halt ehemalige Freunde an, die aber noch in der Politik tätig sind und das ist halt extrem problematisch, deswegen versuchen wir da ähm.
Mit Karenzzeiten so eine Art Abkühlung äh einzuführen, aber wie gesagt, das wird überhaupt
gemacht bisher und deswegen ist die Politik von Herrn halt auch extrem industriefreundlich erachtet, immer darauf, dass die europäische Digitalwirtschaft an erster Stelle kommt und äh um Werte oder um Bürgerrechte äh geht's ihm da kaum.
Und ich kann mir, also das muss ja noch nicht mal eine böse Absicht
sein, das ist einfach auch ganz normal, wenn der sein Leben lang in der Wirtschaft rumgehangen hat in diesem Bereich, dann wird er jetzt nicht auf einmal zum flammenden Bürgerrechtler, um ähm mit mit seiner.
Mit seiner Branche aufzuräumen, ja? Also das das äh kann theoretisch mal einem Menschen passieren, aber es ist eben sehr viel wahrscheinlicher, dass der einfach genau das, was er
vorher hat er ja diese Werte, äh hat er auch dann eben diese Werte nicht vertreten oder sich eben so verhalten. Finde ich halt ziemlich ähm.
Also da muss da noch nicht mal eine böse Absicht.
Selbst haben oder irgendwelche eigenen Ideale oder sonst was verletzen, ist einfach ganz normal, dass er eben so weitermachen wird, äh wie er's äh wie er's immer gemacht hat und seine Perspektive behalten wird, ne.
Ja, richtig. Es geht da auch nicht immer nur um Kompetenz. Also du könntest ja, wenn du jemand kompetentes äh im Thema digitales haben willst, auch aus der Wirtschaft, äh aus der Wissenschaft zum Beispiel jemanden holen. Aber das Problem ist halt,
nominiert werden die Kommissare von den Regierungschefs. Also in dem Fall bei Bretton war's halt ähm der französische Präsident,
Macron, der ihn nominiert hat und äh die sind halt befreundet. Die haben schon vorher miteinander zusammengearbeitet. Ich weiß nicht, ob er Formal Parteimitglied ist, aber meistens spielen halt solche Sachen viel eher eine Rolle, da das Netzwerk
ähm die die Parteimitgliedschaft oder irgendwie Zusammenarbeit in der Vergangenheit als äh Kompetenz
jetzt noch Kompetenz dazu kommt, ist es natürlich erfreulich, aber wie gesagt, Drehtürwechsel direkt aus der Wirtschaft geht gar nicht. Wir haben damals versucht, das zu verhindern. Es gibt dem Europäischen Parlament den Rechtsausschuss, wo ich auch Mitglied bin,
der so eine Art Ethikprüfung auf Interessenskonflikte durchführt, äh aber letzten Endes war es so, ähm dass die großen Parteien, also
Liberale, die ihn nominiert hat, ähm Konservative und Sozialdemokraten, dass die gegenseitig ihre Kandidaten gestützt haben.
Klar. Also leider, leider selbstverständlich, wir.
Äh ich hatte jetzt gerade schon gesagt, du warst dann im ähm äh Landtag in äh Schleswig-Holstein. Du wurdest dann die Wahlen waren zwanzig neunzehn, ne?
Ins EU-Parlament gewählt und man könnte sagen.
Julia Reeder war die einzige deutsche Piratenabgeordnete, oder?
Genau, Julia war die Einzige. Es gab davor schon äh schwedische Piratenabgeordnete im Europäischen Parlament. Und jetzt aktuell sind wir wirklich zu viert. Zum ersten Mal.
Europaweit zu viert, aber du bist auch der einzige Deutsche gerade im Europaparlament von den Piraten.
Genau, der einzige Deutsche und dann noch drei tschechische äh Kolleginnen und Kollegen.
Und in dem in diesem Kontext könnte man sagen, du bist jetzt zu dir der Nachfolger von Julia Reeder als der einzige äh deutsche Piratenabgeordnete im EU-Parlament mit eben auch sehr ähnlichen Themenbereichen.
Ja, sie hat ja sehr große Fußstapfen wirklich hinterlassen und ich glaube gar nicht, dass ich die so gut ähm ausfüllen kann. Sie war ja.
Aber jetzt tut mir leid.
So, jetzt dreh dich mal nicht raus hier.
War eine super Kommunikatorin und hat es geschafft, diese Themen auch wirklich gut ähm rüberzubringen. Und außerdem hat sie sich halt entschieden, sich wirklich auf ein Thema äh ganz groß zu fokussieren, nämlich auf die urheberrechts.
Und äh mein Schwerpunkt ist halt ein bisschen anders, äh weil ich halt vor allem Bürgerrechte ähm Recht auf Privatsphäre,
aber jetzt halt auch viel Recht auf freie Meinungsäußerung ähm im in dem digitalen Zeitalter,
bediene und ich bin deswegen auch nicht im Binnenmarktausschuss Mitglied, wo Julia aktiv war, sondern im Bürgerrechtsausschuss Hauptmitglied.
Ist das der lieb bliebe.
Genau, stellvertretendes Mitglied im Rechtsausschuss. Juri. Da war allerdings Julia auch drin, das heißt,
Urheberrechtsthemen und speziell Axel Voss begleiten mich weiterhin äh als als Kollege bei allen möglichen Themen. Aber ansonsten können wir uns jetzt besser aufteilen, weil wir zu viert sind, also,
Binnenmarkt macht Marcel, mein tschechischer Kollege, der auch,
Vizepräsident des Europäischen Parlaments jetzt ist. Das stellen wir inzwischen auch ähm dann Industriethemen, also ähm
Forschungsförderung und digital Breitbart und so weiter macht Nicolasch ähm auch ein tschechischer Kollege.
Und ähm Außenpolitik, Desinformation, ähm Cyber, Waffen und so weiter, macht Markette auch eine tschechische Kollegin.
Wir werden die dann mal noch äh ein bisschen in unseren Shownotes verlinken und äh auf ein Auge draufhalten. Und wir haben uns heute drei.
Drei Primärthemen, die ihr gerade so äh auf der Ebene brodeln, rausgesucht, das ist einmal.
Glaube ich, ne? Dann haben wir den den DSA Digital Services Act und dann wird müssen wir nochmal sprechen über die Abweichung von der E-Privacy-Richtlinie.
Mit welchem Thema fangen wir denn jetzt mal an? Ich würde sagen, also wahrscheinlich Terrek, oder?
Ja, gerne. Es ist ja eine sperrige Abkürzung, aber eigentlich heißt die Verordnung,
die geplant ist, ähm Verordnung zur Verhinderung terroristischer Inhalte im Netz.
Und ähm allein schon dieser Anspruch, nämlich sowas verhindern zu können, was natürlich völlig unrealistisch ist, ähm hat dazu geführt, dass das Europäische Parlament diesen Titel schon ändern will.
Terroristische Inhalte damit gemeint ist halt quasi Propaganda ne? Das heißt.
Entweder die von terroristischen Gruppierungen selbst erzeugt wird, gerade der IS äh war da sehr professionell.
Was Propaganda anging, hat er auch eigene Musik produziert und so weiter und so fort. Ähm aber es kann können auch Materialien von anderen sein
und da wird's dann eben auch gefährlich, ähm denn die Entscheidung, was ist terroristische Propaganda,
und was ist zum Beispiel Berichterstattung über Terrorismus, also Pressefreiheit.
Was ist äh Kunstfreiheit, ja? Ähm Rapper haben ja auch oft gerne äh Gangster, Texte und sowas gibt's natürlich auch im Bereich Islam.
Hast du nicht auch mal so ein Rap-Video gemacht irgendwie.
Stimmt. Lasst uns auf sie los.
Ich habe auch ein Rap-Video gemacht, ja? Könnt ihr gern verlinken.
Bist du auch so ein Gangster.
Gangster.
Nee, das jetzt nur nicht gerade.
Da hast du eigentlich noch Glück gehabt, ne? Mit also lasst es auf sie los. Ist ja gefährlich nah dran an. Wir werden sie jagen, aber nee, alles ist schön. Das machen wir als Auto, glaube ich, mal. Oder als als Bonustrick, ja.
Aber du, es ist schon ein bisschen was dran, weil ähm bestimmte Sachen, wenn wir nicht im Parlament wären würden, nicht behandelt oder nicht angegangen werden. Also es ist schon so, dass es echt viel ausmacht, ähm
damit vertreten zu sein, weil, wie gesagt, andere haben diesen Schwerpunkt nicht. Äh Digitales, Bürgerrechte und so weiter, ne. Deswegen äh hat man uns da schon auf einige Leute losgelassen und wir haben uns da auch schon kräftig unbeliebt,
bei einigen EU-Kommissaren.
Unterstimm ich auch hundert Prozent zu. Also das wird ja das äh zieht auch glaube ich niemand in Zweifel. Hm ich glaube wenn man ihm Gelegenheit gibt äh quengelt Axel Voss ja heute noch dass ihn ähm.
Seine schöne Urheberrechtsreform im Prinzip von einer einzigen Abgeordneten die ganze Zeit äh angegriffen und letztendlich auch nachhaltig äh verhagelt wurde.
Ja, wenn Julia das dieses Engagement da nicht gezeigt hätte, ähm.
Also wenn wir Julia nicht darauf losgelassen hätten, wäre da sicherlich einiges anders gelaufen, also hast du absolut recht.
Ja, das ist auch das Tolle in, in Brüssel, dass du halt nicht diesen Fraktionszwang hast, ne? Du arbeitest echt mit äh Kollegen, auch aus anderen Fraktionen zusammen.
Sehr eng, zum Beispiel jetzt hier in meinem Fall Timo Wölken oder,
von den Liberalen und du kannst halt dadurch richtig viel erreichen, weil man durch diese Netzwerke und die gemeinsamen Interessen und Themen
ähm Verbündete viel finden kann zu Themen, die andere vielleicht nicht so interessieren,
und dann hängt es letzten Endes an wenigen Personen ab. Ähm was so ein Ergebnis sein kann, vor so einem Gesetzgebungsvorhaben. Und diese Tarikverordnung, über die wir jetzt gerade sprechen,
ist letzten Endes auch ein Beispiel,
dafür wo ich sagen kann dass unser Engagement und ich verhandel diese Verordnung für meine Fraktion das ist die Fraktion Grüne, Europäische Freie Allianz
dass ohne unser Engagement für Internet, Meinungsfreiheit zu diesem Thema,
die Verordnung wahrscheinlich schon durch wäre und es könnten darin enthalten sein, deswegen ist sie so gefährlich.
Uploadfilter gegen terroristische Inhalte und ähm ja, grenzüberschreitende schnell Löschanordnungen. Das heißt, eine ungarische Behörde, die Orban untersteht,
lässt halt plötzlich in Deutschland irgendwelche Internetinhalte löschen, weil sie sagen, das sei terroristische Propaganda und der Begriff Terrorismus ist sehr vage. Es gibt da keine EU-weit anerkannte mh Definition
Manche halten Separatisten für Terroristen, zum Beispiel in Spanien ist das teilweise so gewesen.
Orban hat auch mal einen Migranten mit Antiterrorismusgesetzen verfolgt. In Frankreich wurden äh ähm Antiterrorismusgesetze gegen diese sozialen Proteste.
Letztes Jahr angewendet als man gegen Rentenreform da protestiert hatte.
Und ähm deswegen ist halt die Gefahr groß, dass äh solche äh Möglichkeiten, Inhalte filtern oder löschen zu lassen,
genutzt werden gegen politisch äh,
inopportune Botschaften und da kann ganz schnell hinten runterfallen Berichterstattung über Terrorismus, äh äh Kunst,
in Spanien hat man zum Beispiel Satiriker.
Verfolgt juristisch, die sich eigentlich einfach lustig gemacht haben über Antiterrormaßnahmen, zum Beispiel. Ähm es geht auch um die Wissenschaft.
Wissenschaftler beschäftigen sich ja auch mit dem Phänomen Terrorismus und brauchen natürlich auch die Informationen, die terroristische Gruppierung produzieren.
Um ähm das analysieren zu können.
Ähm es gibt auch ähm Gruppen, die Menschenrechtsverletzungen dokumentieren, natürlich auch ähm in Syrien zum Beispiel und darauf angewiesen sind, dass sie ähm ja,
solche Dokumentationen unterhalten können und allgemein die die kritische Auseinandersetzung mit Terrorismus,
braucht halt auch die Möglichkeit, ähm so was kommentieren zu können, Bilder und Videos, vielleicht ähm kommentieren zu können.
Und äh das ist ja halt das Problem, gerade mit den Upload-Filtern
wenn es nach EU Kommission und Regierung geht, verbindlich verpflichtend werden sollen, auch zur Terrorismusbekämpfung jetzt, äh dass diese Filter halt
zwar vielleicht bestimmte Inhalte erkennen können, aber halt den Kontext nicht verstehen, die wissen gar nicht, ähm ist das ein Propaganda-Kontext
oder ist das 'ne Zeitschrift, ein Online-Medium, die ein Foto halt verwenden zur Illustrierung eines kritischen Artikels, ja?
Und äh deswegen dieses Overblocking-Problem deswegen versuchen wir von Seiten des Parlaments und da gibt es eine Mehrheit
Übrigens, wahrscheinlich auch zu verdanken den Urheberrechtsreformprotesten. Also die Parlamentsmehrheit ist gegen verpflichtende Terror-Uploadfilter und wir versuchen, das rauszuhalten. Ähm,
allerdings der die großen Plattformen setzen, die Filter auch freiwillig ein, muss man ganz klar sagen. Und das führt dann oft halt tatsächlich dazu, dass,
fälschlich gesperrt wird. YouTube selbst hat als Beispiel genannt, ähm.
Dass man eine Parlamentsdebatte über Folter zum Beispiel blockiert hat, ne, weil irgendwie Folter vorkam, ähm und dass man ähm.
Wie gesagt, dokumentierte Menschenrechtsverletzung im in Syrien halt runtergenommen hat, weil die halt tatsächlich Kriegszenen oder Gewalt zeigen.
Aber es gibt halt eine Gruppierung äh nennen die sich, die halt wirklich sich zur Aufgabe gemacht hatten, ähm solche.
Videoaufnahmen zu sammeln, damit dann später halt auch Menschenrechtsverletzungen geändert werden können und YouTube hat halt das den größten Teil von deren Archiv dann einfach gelöscht.
Jetzt ist ja, sagen wir mal, diese Argumentation mit Filter können dazu führen, dass legitimes Material nicht online gerät.
In unseren Kreisen recht bekannt, populär und viel zitiert. Wie siehst du denn das selber,
Ähm also wie siehst du denn selber quasi die Dringlichkeit, dass man aufgrund von Inhalten in Netzen was tun muss.
Mal ganz von den Nebeneffekten mal abgesehen.
Na ja, du du sprichst natürlich die ganz grundsätzliche Frage an, ob man mit so einer Verordnung,
zu einer stärkeren Löschung terroristischer Propaganda äh führen soll. Ob man damit halt tatsächlich Terrorismus eindämmen kann, ne? Und da würde ich schon ein ein großes Fragezeichen dahinter machen, wie.
Effektiv, dass letzten Endes zum Schutz vor Terrorismus ist, denn zum einen ist es so.
Wenn wenn terroristische Gruppierungen sozusagen Nachwuchs anwerben wollen.
Dann ist das selten mit Videos, die irgendwie Anschläge verherrlichen, sondern der Einstieg ist immer sehr viel subtiler
da da knüpfen die einfach an Kritik an, an Missständen, ja, dass etwas ungerecht ist, äh dass
Kriege oder Menschenrechtsverletzungen, die ja auch die USA zum Beispiel ähm zu verantworten haben. Ähm wie wie ähm
die muslimische Gemeinschaft behandelt wird in einigen Ländern.
Ähm Guyantano ist sicherlich ein Extrembeispiel, aber die knüpfen erstmal an irgendwie legitime Kritik an, vielleicht auch an Religion
Also der Großteil dieser dieser Einstiegs ähm Botschaften sind gar nicht verboten und würden auch nicht unter diese Verordnung fallen.
Und dann ist es so, wenn du dich wirklich konkret für so eine terroristische Gruppierung ähm,
interessierst, dann wirst du der natürlich nicht auf Facebook oder Twitter folgen, ja, weil die ähm machen heute schon alles, um dieses Zeug ähm,
diese Propaganda zu löschen, sondern dann benutzt du halt ähm einen verschlüsselten Messenger zum Beispiel und ähm schließt dich da entsprechenden Chatkanälen an oder wie auch immer, äh was auch diese Verordnung nicht nicht verhindern könnte, ne.
Also deswegen,
ob man dadurch wirklich die Rekrutierung von Terroristen verhindern kann, ist eine ganz große Frage. Und ähm ich sehe das eher kritisch,
andererseits ähm klar, es gibt bestimmte Inhalte, die verboten sind, aus aus guten Gründen, äh
menschenverachtende Inhalte, Aufrufe zu Gewalt und so weiter. Und dass man dann gezielt versucht, die zu löschen, ist natürlich ein legitimes Anliegen und das muss dann auch grundrechtsfreundlich ähm.
Geregelt werden, aber aus meiner, nach meiner Überzeugung muss die Entscheidung halt letzten Endes ähm.
Von der unabhängigen öffentlichen Behörde verantwortet werden. Denn wenn die Plattform entscheiden, die haben da irgendwie
Klickwerker, die unter prekären Bedingungen arbeiten, die vielleicht fünf Sekunden Zeit haben, um über irgendeinen Inhalt zu entscheiden. Ähm da ist echt die Meinungsfreiheit in Gefahr, wenn man solche Privatsensoren ähm
einsetzt. Und deswegen versuchen wir halt ein Verfahren zu erreichen,
wo eine öffentliche Behörde, die gegen deren Entscheidungen, die im Zweifel auch gerichtlich vorgehen kannst, ähm Löschlöschungen anordnet, nachdem sie geprüft hat,
ob der Inhalt wirklich terroristischer Natur ist. Und zwar in Einbeziehung des Kontextes und im Einzelfall.
Bekommt natürlich dann schnell das Argument mit, das ist ja alles viel zu schnell und viel zu viel und äh da ist die Geschwindigkeit zu einer Behörde ja niemals in der Lage hier in irgendeiner Form effektiv gegen vorgehen zu können.
Ja genau, das Argument kommt, dass du damit die Masse an Inhalten nicht in den Griff bekommst und das das stimmt natürlich auch und da ist halt dann die Frage, wie wächst du das ab? Ähm nutzen und schaden
Meiner Meinung nach ist der Nutzen
solche Propaganda rauszufinden, halt gering, wenn es darum geht, wirklich terroristische Anschläge zu verhindern, ist, glaube ich, kaum, dass es äh gering wird, mit so einem Instrument
glaube, da bräuchte es ganz andere Maßnahmen, wenn du Terrorismus vorbeugen, vorbeugen wolltest. Und andererseits ist der Schaden halt sehr hoch, wenn du diese automatischen Filter einsetzt, denn selbst wenn du identisches Material filterst,
kann es halt sein, dass dieses Material in einem
legalen Kontext verwendet wird und dann äh im Klo verschwindet, nimmt zum Beispiel ähm Bilder oder Dokumentationen von terroristischen Anschlägen.
Das kann ja sowohl zu Propagandazwecken verwendet werden, aber dasselbe Foto, dasselbe Video, auch zur Berichterstattung, ne.
Haben übrigens erinnere ich mich grade auf dem dreiunddreißig C3 auch ein Vortrag gehalten, denn,
Dokumentation von Menschenrechtsverletzung geht, die du gerne gesprochen hast. Ähm es gibt ja noch, wie ich finde, ein,
anderes sehr wichtiges Argument zu diesen Uploadfiltern, ähm dass ich äh.
Was teilweise ein bisschen unter ähbelichtet war
und deswegen hatten wir das damals als CCC auch nochmal ein bisschen versucht zu betonen und das ist na ja, welche Plattform kann sich denn überhaupt leisten, so etwas zu bauen, ne? Und in in Funktionierend und das, was letztendlich ähm
passieren wird, ist das äh oder was ja auch bei der Urheberrechtsreform immer wieder die große Diskussion war, dass sie dann dass sie ähm.
Versuchen die kleineren Plattformen davon auszunehmen, während sie versuchen, die größeren Plattformen dazu zu zwingen.
Was gleichzeitig wiederum dazu führt, dass du dann deine äh Urheberrechtsverletzung, Terroristen oder was auch immer du jetzt da gerade anziehst, eben.
Drängst von da wo es ist. Wenn du sagst aber wiederum, das würde gleichmäßig äh du würdest das gleichmäßig verfiltern und sagen, das muss jetzt,
jede Plattform machen, dann erschwerst du es den Kleinen überhaupt zu überleben und treibst ihn letztendlich.
Dahin, dass sie die den Uploadfilter von jemand anderem ist es Service kaufen müssen oder bekommen müssen. Und das wäre dann wiederum die große Plattform.
Von äh von Google oder Facebook. Die sagt, komm bei euch das kleine bisschen Traffic, was ihr habt, können wir auch noch äh das kleine bisschen Uploads, was ihr habt, können wir auch noch filtern, was ja dann eben in diesem wirtschaftlichen Bereich auch wirklich sehr
unerwünscht wäre, ne, weil du eine wirklich so eine zentrale Privatwirtschaftliche Zensurinfrastruktur dann hättet.
Ja, das ist in der Tat ein Problem von dieser geplanten Verordnung, dass der Anwendungsbereich, also die betroffenen Dienste, sehr weit ist und zwar im Grunde genommen soll die Anwendung finden, auf alle Hosting-Dienste, Anbieter, das heißt, alle.
Irgendwie Inhalte.
Am speichern für für Dritte sozusagen, ne? Und das sind ja eigentlich sämtliche Dienste, das sind auch nichtkommerzielle Dienste, das ist jedes Blog, wenn du zum Beispiel eine Kommentarfunktion hast, dann speicherst du auch.
Quasi Inhalte, die von anderen eingegeben wurden, ja? Und.
Ist natürlich völlig unrealistisch, sowas wie wie Upload-Filter von allen diesen Dienstanbietern zu verlangen. Aber halt auch dieser dieser Plan,
über den wir im Moment besonders intensiv streiten mit diesen Löschanordnungen, diesen grenzüberschreitenden,
die ja innerhalb einer Stunde durchzuführen sein sollen. Das ist ja auch völlig unrealistisch, diese Einstundenfrist, dass du das überhaupt einhalten kannst, gerade,
das würde ja auch nachts soll das gelten, das soll am Wochenende gelten,
ähm du kriegst dann irgendwann mal vielleicht eine eine E-Mail oder irgendwie du kriegst das gar nicht mit. Und wenn du das dann als als Dienst dann wieder nicht innerhalb einer Stunde gelöscht hast, drohen halt auch sehr hohe Strafen, ne
Und das ist ja ein ein Wahnsinn, diese Einstundenregel auf alle, auch kleine Anbieter äh anzuwenden. Da, da kämpfen wir echt hart. Ähm.
Dass es da Ausnahmen gibt für Fällen, wo wo man die Frist einfach ohne eigenes Verschulden auch nicht ähm realistischerweise einhalten kann. Man muss ja auch bedenken, es ist leicht,
wenn ich eine eine Plattform trollen oder kaputtmachen will,
poste ich einfach immer wieder den Inhalt da, ne? Also viele haben ja eine Kommentarfunktion oder Vicky oder wie auch immer und ähm du kannst dir damit auch Plattformen gezielt kaputt machen.
Wie ist denn der aktuelle Stand jetzt eigentlich in dieser Geschichte? Kannst du nochmal kurz skizzieren, in welchem ähm in welcher Phase der Beratung sich das befindet und wie schätzt du ein, was da letztlich bei rauskommen wird?
Ich glaube, wir sind ja in der finalen Handlungsphase. Es ist ähm in der EU immer so, dass die EU-Kommission einen Vorschlag macht, äh dann ähm finden Parlament und Rat, das heißt, die EU-Regierung,
nochmal eigene Position also was sie gerne ändern würden an dem Vorschlag und dann finden Verhandlungen statt die sogenannten Triloge.
Deswegen, weil da halt alle drei Institutionen ähm Kommission, Parlament und Rat an einem Tisch sitzen und miteinander verhandeln und am Ende müssen sich halt Parlament und Rat einigen. Wenn beide zustimmen, dann wird sowas Gesetz.
Und diese Triloge finden leider hinter verschlossenen Türen statt. Wir haben jetzt letzte Woche grad so eine Verhandlungsrunde gehabt und äh Ende Oktober ist die nächste, also so etwa monatlich. Dazwischen treffen sich die Mitarbeiter auf, auf technischer Ebene, um.
Kleinere Sachen ähm auszuhandeln und und vorzubereiten. Und die äh diese Ratspräsidentschaft, also wer.
Wer die Regierung vertritt, das wechselt alle sechs Monate. Im Moment ist es Deutschland.
Hat die Ratspräsidentschaft inne und die haben halt den Anspruch, dass sie diese Verhandlung zu einem,
Abschluss bringen wollen bevor vor dem nächsten Wechsel. Das heißt, bis Ende des Jahres. Und das kann sein.
Dass es tatsächlich gelingt, weil die Fraktion im Parlament zwar eine gute Ausgangsposition äh beschlossen haben, also im Sinne von Bürgerrechte und auch ähm,
ja digitalen Anbieter, aber halt in unterschiedlichen Maße bereit sind ähm Kompromisse einzugehen.
Weil viele diese Verordnung halt sehr wichtig finden,
und ähm ja, da sehr flexibel sind in den ein oder anderen Punkten. Ähm die größte Gefahr ist wahrscheinlich.
Bei diesen grenzüberschreitenden Anordnungen, dass das Parlament, was das ursprünglich abgelehnt hat, äh dem doch zustimmen könnte, mehrheitlich.
Was dann halt wie gesagt dazu führt, dass.
Ja, Inhalte gelöscht werden müssen, wenn nur eine Behörde äh in der ganzen EU.
Ähm das anordnet. Also jede Behörde könnte ähm in jedem Land, auch in Deutschland, die Löschung von Inhalten anordnen lassen, die man vielleicht bei uns für legitim, für legal ansehen würde, die aber halt im Ausland.
Ähm ja ähm unbeliebt sind.
Und es gibt ja zum Beispiel in Ungarn Online-Medien, die gerade deswegen aus dem Ausland heraus operieren, weil sie halt in Ungarn nicht mehr frei berichten können. Wenn jetzt die ungarische Regierung da Löschungen anordnen kann,
ähm sehe ich da wirklich schwarz ähm was die Pressefreiheit angeht.
Nicht in der Hinsicht absolut erforderlich. Zunächst einmal wirklich eine wasserdichte Definition von Terror, also einfach auch mal zu liefern, also damit das eben nicht wischiwaschi bleibt.
Ja, diese Verordnung enthält eine Definition von sogenannten terroristischen Inhalten. Äh zum einen ist diese Definition sehr weit, also die Regierung wollen zum Beispiel schon die Unterstützung terroristischer Aktivitäten einbeziehen,
und das ist so wage, das kann letzten Endes schon eine Berichterstattung sein, die,
meinetwegen ein Interview mit einem Terroristen oder so, könnte vielleicht schon als Unterstützung gewertet werden, also es ist gefährlich weit.
Nehmen wir ein schönes Beispiel. Ein Mensch sagt ähm.
Äh oder wie der wie der Satz war, ne? Terroristische Vereinigung, der er im Prinzip äh,
dir zurückpfeift und auf sein Kommando warten lässt. Ja, eindeutige Unterstützung äh terroristische Aktivitäten. In meinen Augen.
Genau, könnte man, könnte man darunter fassen. Letzten Endes ist es aber so, selbst wenn du die Definition auf dem Papier einheitlich hast, die Anwendung dieser Begriffe,
und auch der Ausnahmen, die wir einführen wollen. Wir wollen ja,
Ausnahmen einführen für geschützte journalistische Inhalte, für wissenschaftliche Inhalte und so weiter. Und die Anwendung dieser ganzen Begriffe,
äh ist im Endeffekt dann doch Sache der.
Polizei in auf Malta, in Ungarn, in Irland, wo auch immer, ne? Also die wird völlig unterschiedlich ausfallen. Auch wenn du eine einheitliche Definition hast,
zum Beispiel schon keine Einigung darauf, welche Gruppierungen tatsächlich terroristische Gruppierungen sind, ne. Wie ich schon sagte, hier am Beispiel der katalonischen äh Separat.
Aber auch ähm.
Weiß nicht, ähm in Palästina oder ähm da streitet man sich oft darüber, auch innerhalb der EU, sind das Freiheitskämpfer oder sind das Terroristen?
Da müsste sich ja dieser Dissens im Prinzip auch äh auf so eine europäischen Achse in irgendeiner Form auch widerspiegeln oder hast du den Eindruck, dass hier,
Ähm Pro und Contra gegenüber dieser Regulierung eher eine Sache der Fraktion ist oder gibt's da auch wieder so eine Nord-Süd-Ost-West.
Unterschiede. Hat man ja manchmal.
Ja, also im Parlament ist es so, dass ähm das Parlament eine ziemlich gute
Ursprungsposition letztes Jahr beschlossen hatte, noch kurz vor der Europawahl und die wurde von allen Fraktionen mitgetragen, außer von den Konservativen. Also denen konnte es von Anfang an schon nicht schnell und weit genug gehen. Die wollten verpflichten der Uploadfilter, die Wolken grenzüberschreiende Ordnung und so weiter und so fort
Also die sind sowieso schon mal äh ähm außen vor. Dann ist es so, dass die.
Ähm also eine Fraktion, die jetzt nicht die die Christdemokraten sind, äh sondern die eigentlich noch äh ähm konservativer sind.
Ähm und auch die Liberalen, die für die ist diese Verordnung sehr wichtig und die sind ähm,
bereit ähm auch problematische.
Ähm Kompromisse einzugehen. Und das liegt, glaube ich, schon so ein bisschen an der politischen Ausrichtung. Man muss wissen, dass die Liberalen auf europäischer Ebene,
vor allem auch von den Franzosen dominiert werden, weil ja äh Macrons ähm
Partei denen beigetreten ist und ähm was Macron im Antiterrorkampf alles zu tun bereit ist, hat, glaube ich, der Ausnahmezustand äh,
der da lange Zeit vorgeherrscht hat. Und ähm die Einschränkung der Bürgerrechte, die da ähm vorgenommen worden sind und was die EU Regierung angeht,
ist es, glaube ich, in der Tat so, dass gerade die Länder, wo schon Anschläge stattgefunden haben, das heißt, ähm Frankreich, Spanien.
Aber auch teilweise Italien. So sieht Europa. Also vielleicht auch ein bisschen die Länder, die in der Copyright-Debatte da unangenehm aufgefallen sind, dass die für sehr,
weitreichende äh Maßnahmen sind. So weit reichen, dass sogar der französische Verfassungsgerichtshof ein französisches Gesetz, was,
ähnliches vorgeschrieben hat, ja? Ein Stundenlöschung von terroristischen, anderen Inhalten, ähm für verfassungswidrig erklärt hat vor einigen Wochen
und die nordischen Länder und die ähm ja östlichen Länder
sind, glaube ich, eher so ein bisschen äh vorsichtiger, schützen eher die Meinungsfreiheit oder sind auch ein bisschen mehr auf die Geschäftsinteressen bedacht. Aber das Problem bei dieser Verordnung ist, äh viele Länder sind da gar nicht dran interessiert,
Das heißt, die bringen sich nicht so in die Verhandlungen ein und hauptsächlich die Scharfmacher.
Die ähm machen sich sehr stark und drängen und pochen und machen Druck. Und das ist halt die Gefahr, dass wenn das unter dem Radar der Öffentlichkeit läuft, dass hier ein Präzedenzfall geschaffen wird. Das heißt, eine Verordnung.
Terrorinhalte, die sehr weitreichende Zensur und Löschung vorsieht und dass das dann halt genutzt werden kann in Zukunft für andere Zwecke, für andere Inhalte, die unerwünscht sind, sei es Urheberrechtsverstöße.
Sei es Hasskriminalität oder vielleicht irgendwann auch für Fake News, Desinformationen oder sonstige einfach.
Ähm unliebsame Inhalte. Und das ist die große Gefahr.
Ich denke, diese diese Gefahr kann man auch gar nicht ähm oft genug hervorkehren, weil ja auch die
Verlauf der politischen Debatten und der Verlauf der sagen wir mal äh Grundrechtseinschränkungen und Überwachungsmaßnahmen genau dieser ist, dass die am Anfang,
über Terrorismus oder dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauch oder ähnliches,
in ganz besonderen Sonderfällen eingeführt werden und sich Jahrzehnt später.
Im Prinzip zum Alltagsermittlungstool der äh der Dorfpolizei entwickeln oder zwei Jahrzehnten. Und das ist ja,
nun wirklich bei den meisten derartiger Maßnahmen. Ähm.
Tatsächlich sichtbar. Insofern sehe ich auch hier also oder belegbar an der Geschichte. Und äh da sehe ich auch hier so ein bisschen die große Sorge mit dieser einen Stunde, die da gegeben wird, weil.
Für jeden, der irgendwie halbwegs.
Sinnvoll über diesen, über diese Anforderung mit der Stunde nachdenkt, heißt das dann letztendlich, dass man irgendeine Form von Unified Excess geben wird, ne, dass man sagt, okay
Leute äh wir wir gehen jetzt mal davon aus, dass ihr diese Möglichkeit nicht missbraucht und wir geben euch hier den, den Extrabutton, wenn ihr als
EU-Behörde eingeloggt seid, dann wird hier nicht eure Beschwerde geprüft oder sonst was, sondern die wird einfach ihr könnt die Sachen im Prinzip einfach wegklicken
ihr kriegt einfach eine eine Durchgangsinfrastruktur, wo wir nicht mehr prüfen. Dafür stellen wir jetzt keinen kein Team an, was vierundzwanzig Stunden eure Löschanträge prüft, ne? Und dann hast du etabliert sich erstmal so eine schöne EPI, wo die.
Die Behörden nach Lust und Laune von Gebrauch machen, dann machen wir das wie bei den Datenabfragen durch unsere Polizeibeamtinnen, dass wir jede Zweihundertste mal stichprobenartig prüfen.
Und ähm dann parallel dazu findet dann die Diskussion statt, dass die Leute sagen, ja äh Terrorismus
schon gefiltert, jetzt wollen wir das auch für Urheberrecht oder Urheberrecht und Terrorismus wird eh schon jetzt hätten wir das gerne auch für, was weiß ich
fällt uns schon noch was ein, was uns nicht gefällt. In den nächsten Jahren. Und das halte ich für ja,
das wird immer so runtergespielt, wenn man wenn man so ein Argument anbringt, so, ja, ja, ihr stellt euch da immer wieder an, ihr habt jetzt schon wieder den Überwachungsstaat vor Augen, aber tatsächlich zeigt doch die Geschichte, dass es genauso immer läuft.
Genau, wir haben's ja einfach immer wieder erlebt, ähm bei welchem Thema auch immer und äh deswegen äh finden wir da inzwischen halt absolut das Vertrauen, dass irgendwas ähm
beschränkt bleiben wird. Wenn es jetzt wirklich so wäre, dass ähm eine unabhängige öffentliche Stelle nach Prüfung im Einzelfall einen bestimmten Inhalt markiert, dann würde ich auch sagen, ist es in Ordnung, wenn die.
Wenn der Hoaster das ähm automatisch äh ähm oder wenn er das automatisch löscht ohne weitere Prüfung, ich würde mich eh nicht drauf verlassen, dass ähm der Hosting Service Provider sich irgendwie in die Bresche wirft für,
problematische Inhalte, grenzwertige Inhalte, die im Zweifelsfall ja nicht viele,
haben und ähm nicht große Reichweite haben und halt auch nicht viel Werbegelder einspielen. Da haben die gar keinen, gar keinen Anreiz, sich dafür einzusetzen. Und deswegen haben wir halt reingeschrieben oder wir versuchen halt reinzuschreiben.
Erstens, dass das Verfahren um so eine Löschung äh ähm durchzuführen,
möglichst gut designt ist und zweitens, dass der Uploader selbst halt dann Rechtsmittel hat und ähm sich gegen so eine Löschung zur Wehr setzen kann. Und das kann er halt sehr viel besser,
wenn das eine Entscheidung der Behörde ist, weil dagegen kannst du einfach vor Gericht ziehen, als wenn der äh Plattformbetreiber einfach selbst das entscheidet. Und genau das Problem haben wir im Moment,
Plattformbetreiber wenden ja nicht die Gesetze an, sondern die wenden ihre ähm AGB an. Und da kann jeder Plattformbetreiber eigentlich willkürlich reinschreiben,
welche Inhalte ihm unerwünscht sind oder dass er sich einfach vorbehält überhaupt alles zu löschen und zu sperren und ähm das ist halt ein ein riesen Problem,
wo gerade auch benachteiligte Gruppen ähm drunter leiden, die äh Probleme haben, zum Beispiel auf auf TikTok oder wie auch immer.
Inhalte unterzubringen, das kann von behinderten Menschen sein, das kann von Menschen mit anderer sexueller Orientierung sein.
Und ähm deswegen wollen wir halt diese Löscheinung ähm in der in der Hand einer öffentlichen Behörde,
haben. Leider ist aber schon dieses Merkmal unabhängig hinten runtergefallen, ne? Im Endeffekt werden es wahrscheinlich Polizeibehörden sein, die,
Entfernung von Internetseiten anordnen und ähm ja, wir versuchen, das transparent zu machen. Also wir Berichte halt, was ist gelöscht worden
Und äh zum anderen äh halt die Betroffenen zu benachrichtigen, die uploade, dass sie die Chance haben, auch dagegen anzugehen, wenn der Missbrauch ähm getrieben wird. Aber wie gesagt, noch ist vieles nicht entschieden. Ähm und,
jede Form von öffentlicher Unterstützung äh ist er natürlich willkommen.
Das wird jetzt also, ähm du hast gerade gesagt, so die nächsten Monate uns noch beschäftigen, ne? Aber die Entscheidung steht am Horizont.
Ja, es wird fortlaufend mehr entschieden, ne. Man nähert sich an in den Verhandlungen und ähm ähm die Fraktionen müssen halt entscheiden
welche Punkte opfern sie und welche nicht und wo ist die rote Linie, hinter die sie nicht zurückzugehen bereit sind? Und je mehr äh das ein Thema ist, also die Medien drüber berichten, je mehr Stellungnahmen dazu reinkommen, offene Briefe.
Je mehr Bürger vielleicht auch schreiben.
Desto höher steigt das auf deren Agenda und ähm desto mehr fühlen die sich unter Beobachtung. Und das fehlt im Moment so ein bisschen, weil das ähm.
Keiner auf dem Schirm hat.
Also liebe Hörerinnen, liebe Hörer, macht euch hier stark. Ähm wendet euch an die Öffentlichkeit, wendet euch an eure.
Parlamentarierinnen und zeigt ihnen, dass euch dieses Thema nicht egal ist.
Oder du machst nochmal so ein Gangster-Rap-Video, das könntest du es natürlich.
Das wäre geil.
Sofort gelöscht.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Sag mal, äh okay, wir müssen dann, wir müssen das, das nächste Thema ist, glaube ich, ungleich größer, ne, äh von von seiner äh von seinem Umfang.
Ähm deswegen würde ich jetzt mal so ein bisschen in Richtung des Digital Services Act schielen.
Wenn du nicht noch etwas Wichtiges zum hast.
Nee, das können wir gerne machen, diese äh Tarekverordnung schafft ja vielleicht ein Präzedenzfall für ein Verfahren zur Löschung von Inhalten, was dann allgemein für alle.
Illegalen Inhalte äh übernommen werden könnte, denn die EU Kommission arbeitet oder überarbeitet gerade.
Die sogenannte E-Commerce-Richtlinie. Das ist eine Richtlinie, die ähm ja für.
Ich sag mal ähm Internetdienstleister gilt ja, sei es ähm Hosting Dienste, Anbieter ähm ja,
diejenigen die also quasi Internetpräsenzen selbst betreiben soziale Netzwerke aber auch technische Dienstleister.
Ähm und die bestimmte Anforderung stellt und die deren Haftung regelt, also hafte ich als Anbieter, wenn meine Nutzer.
Illegale Inhalte äh verbreiten oder auch nicht.
Und dieses Riegel weg, was eben schon ein bisschen in die Jahre gekommen sind, soll überarbeitet und leider auch äh verschärft werden. Das heißt, ähm.
Da gibt's schon Überlegungen in Richtung von ähm Internetplattformen, zu so einer Art Internetpolizei oder Internetsensoren zu machen,
Es geht wieder darum, ähm,
Verpflichtung Uploadfilter anzuwenden, wahrscheinlich haben wir es verhindern können. Aber äh es könnte sein, dass das neue Regelwerk die begünstigt, also von der Haftung freistellt, wenn sie es machen. Ähm es könnte.
Vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz erklären, das ist ja also eines der wichtigen Prinzipien des Plattformbetriebes in, ich glaube, weltweit und aber auch mit Sicherheit in Deutschland und Europa ist, dass sich nicht.
Dem.
Zeitpunkt der Veröffentlichung eines Nutzer generierten Inhaltes dafür haftbar bin, sondern erst nach in Kenntnissetzung.
Und das ist ja genau das, was hier ähm durch so Ideen wie Upload-Filter und eben auch im Rahmen des äh Digital Services Act zur Disposition steht, dass man nämlich eben sagt, ja nicht erst, wenn dir jemand sagt, dass das hier,
äh die Rechte verletzt. Bist du dafür verantwortlich, sondern eventuell schon früher?
Ja? Weil du einen Uploadfilter machen musst, weil du sicherstellen musst, dass das gar nicht erst passiert ist. Und das ist doch, also wie man so schön sagt,
eines der wichtigen Prinzipien, die natürlich auch sehr viel Innovation und sehr viel
Nutzer generierte Inhalte überhaupt ermöglicht haben, dass man nämlich sagen kann, okay, ich kann ein StudiVZ bauen
in dem Menschen allen möglichen Kram reinschreiben und ich muss das erstmal nicht filtern. Und wenn wenn ich dann einen melden Button habe, ähm
und dann die die Dinge rausnehmen nach Kenntnisnahme ist das auch in Ordnung. Gilt ja auch für im im Bereich der Urheberrechtsverletzung. Und genau daran soll ja jetzt geschraubt werden, ne.
Genau, also im Moment ist es so, dass du ähm für einen äh fremden Inhalt halt nur ähm haftest im Prinzip.
Wenn du ihn kennst und wenn du auch weißt, dass er rechtswidriger ist, ja? Und das ist natürlich ein ganz wichtiges Prinzip, was halt gerade verhindern soll, dass die.
Plattformen im Voraus alten Gehorsam rein vorsorglich löschen, um halt bloß nicht haftbar zu werden. Genau das ist in einem gewissen Umfang ohnehin schon der Fall.
Weil halt diese Begriffe ähm Kenntnis und so weiter halt ein bisschen ungenau sind und die Gerichte das unterschiedlich auslegen, ähm was da schon
was da schon ausreicht. Bisher steht in der Richtlinie auch drin.
Dass die Anbieter nicht verpflichtet sind, proaktiv selbst allgemein nach rechtswidrigen Inhalten zu forschen. Da hat aber leider der europäische Gerichtshof im Fall einer österreichischen Grünen-Politikerin vor zwei Jahren zu Facebook entschieden.
Ähm dass dieses Verbot der generellen Überwachung nicht entgegenstehen würde, dass Gerichte ähm quasi einen Uploadfilter,
anordnen, der gezielt verhindern soll, dass ein bestimmter Inhalt nochmal gepostet wird oder auch, dass ein vergleichbarer Äquivalenter Inhalt gepostet wird, ja. Das heißt, da reden wir,
nicht nur über Upload-Filter, die nach einem konkreten Inhalt suchen, sondern auch nach AI, künstliche Intelligenz, die versucht, ähnliche Inhalte ähm festzustellen, die dann eine noch höhere,
Fehlerrate hat und ähm das ist hochproblematisch. Ähm wir wollen versuchen oder ich will versuchen.
Dieses Verbot von generellen Überwachungspflichten auszuweiten und auch,
auszuweiten auf generelle Filterpflichten, ähm weiß aber nicht, ob das, ob sich dafür eine eine Mehrheit findet, weil's halt da schon eine Gerichtsentscheidung zu gibt. Und ähm was dieses Haftungsprivileg angeht, also,
dass du nicht für Inhalte haftest, die du nicht kennst. Ähm das soll zwar wohl beibehalten werden, aber es soll eingeführt werden eine sogenannte Sorgfaltspflicht,
Das heißt, die Plattformen werden verpflichtet.
Gewisse Maßnahmen zu machen, um illegalen Inhalten vorzubeugen. Und das ist halt dann quasi das Einfallstor.
Ähm was auch von Gerichten unter Umständen genutzt werden kann,
um da rein zu interpretieren, was man denn alles machen müsste, um vorzubeugen. Ihr erinnert euch vielleicht an das Thema WLAN-Haftung
da waren ja auch die Gerichte sehr kreativ und der Bundesgerichtshof hat letzten Endes entschieden, ja im Grunde genommen um ein Missbrauch deines Wlans äh vorzubeugen,
darfst du es nicht mehr öffnen, ne? Und so ein Unsinn kommt halt dann dabei raus, wenn man nicht ganz präzise sagt, welche Pflichten sollen das denn sein? Und wenn man nicht,
ausschließt, dass sowas dann letzten Endes zu einer generellen Filterung führt.
Okay. Geht es in dem Digital Services Act noch um mehr? Oder also um um weitere Bereiche, weil er soll ja im Prinzip sehr viel.
Neu geregelt werden oder sind, sagen wir, sagen wir uns jetzt auf den Teil konzentriert, der die Bürgerrechte betrifft.
Na ja, es gibt einmal diesen Bereich ähm Eingriff in die Meinungsfreiheit, ne. Da geht's dann halt darum illegale Inhalte
da könnte es auch 'ne zeitliche Vorgabe geben innerhalb deren diese Inhalte runtergenommen werden müssen, da streiten wir weder über das Verfahren
ist dafür zuständig und so weiter und so fort. Aber es geht halt
neben Meinungsfreiheit auch noch zum Beispiel um Privatsphäre äh namentlich, um diese Praxis Targetite Advertising, ja, das auf der Grundlage unserer kompletten Internetnutzung,
Interessensprofile erstellt werden, die er erschreckenderweise wohl,
so genau sind, dass ähm letzten Endes Facebook uns besser kennt äh als äh unser Partner und wahrscheinlich sogar wir selber. Studien zufolge. Und ähm deswegen hoffe ich, dass dieses Thema,
adressiert und und verboten wird. Äh wir haben's auch geschafft, in die Berichte des Europäischen Parlaments, die da so ein bisschen,
Zielvorgaben machen, rein zu verhandeln, ein Recht auf anonyme Internetnutzung. Das heißt,
die Nutzer ein Recht bekommen sollen, soweit das äh möglich ist, Dienste auch anonym zu nutzen. Das bekämpft sozusagen den den Kernnamenszwang und ähm.
Auch Ideen, die aus Deutschland gekommen sind
so eine Art Registrierungs- oder Identifizierungspflicht einzuführen. Es würde natürlich die Urheberrechtslobby sehr gerne sehen, dass man bei allen Internetdiensten nur noch registriert nutzen kann, damit sie irgendwelche Urberichtsverstöße dann leichter,
nachverfolgen können, aber das würde halt ganz viele Menschen ausschließen und auch Whistleblower, die ja oft auch anonym,
Informationen zu spielen oder veröffentlichen müssen. Ja und das dritte Thema ist ähm,
große Thema für mich ist das Thema die großen Plattformen und wie man es schafft, deren quasi Monopolstellung zu
überwinden. Ich bin jemand, der es nicht für realistisch hält, irgendwie die zu zerschlagen oder jetzt, meinetwegen europäisches Facebook aufzubauen, halte ich nicht für realistisch und auch nicht für wirklich zielführend. Das wäre auch nicht besser
sondern ich glaube, wir müssen hinkommen zu offenen ähm dezentralen Netzwerken und das schaffen wir im Endeffekt nur.
Wenn wir diesen Log-in-Effekt überwinden, also,
dass man die großen Plattformen nicht verlassen kann, ohne seine Freunde und Kontakte zu verlieren. Und deswegen ist das große Bassword in dem Zusammenhang interkonnektivität oder interoperabilität. Das heißt, die Idee wäre halt, ähm soziale Netzwerke,
Dienste zumindest die dominanten zu verpflichten, eine API anzubieten, mit der ähm man auch,
über andere Plattformen kommunizieren kann. Ne, so eine Art Vorwahl oder ähm,
Ja, bei E-Mail gibt's ja auch immer den, den Server Identifier, dass man sozusagen dienstübergreifend kommunizieren und anderen
folgen kann. Und ich glaube, wenn man das einführen würde, was man ja im Telefonnetz schon vor Jahrzehnten inzwischen gemacht hat, ähm würden sehr viele Leute wechseln zu,
besseren Systemen, vielleicht auch zu Datenschutzfreundlicheren, offenen Systemen, wenn sie dadurch nicht alle ihre ähm Kontakte mehr verlieren.
Voraus, dass diese Dienste auch äh technisch alle im Prinzip equivalente Dienstleistungen erbringen, wenn man sie denn sozusagen interoperabel gestaltet, das
bedeutet ja, sie müssen überhaupt erstmal eine technische Kompatibilität haben und das bedeutet auch, dass man an kleinsten, gemeinsamen Nenner macht, über denen sich dann halt niemals.
Die volle Funktionalität abbilden lässt, beziehungsweise man die Dienste in gewisser Hinsicht auch.
So ein bisschen davon abhält, äh sich weiter zu diversifizieren und, und, und, und, und die die Technik weiterzuentwickeln.
Also ich denke, das schließt einander nicht aus, wenn du dir zum Beispiel das Beispiel E-Mail anguckst
es gibt ja einzelne Anbieter, die ähm auf den E-Mail-Standard draufsatteln und zum Beispiel sagen, wer unseren Dienst nutzt, kann verschlüsselt miteinander äh kommunizieren oder wie auch immer. Aber in dem Moment
wo du halt eine E-Mail schickst an den Nutzer eines anderen Anbieters.
Da musst du dann den Standard anwenden, also einen gemeinsamen Mindeststandard, wie du sagst, ähm mit dem alle zusammenarbeiten können. Du kannst aber halt für deine eigene Plattform weiterhin ähm zusätzliche,
und Extrafunktionen anbieten,
Ich finde, das schließt einander nicht aus und ich glaube, das könnte den Wettbewerb und die Weiterentwicklung auch ähm sogar begünstigen umgekehrt. Denn im Moment haben ja eigentlich nur die,
Plattformen eine Chance überhaupt Innovationen auch an den Markt bringen zu können, so dass er von vielen genutzt wird und wenn du einen echten Wettbewerb reinbekommst.
Glaube ich würden.
Innovative Anbieter und Geschäftsmodelle eine echte Chance haben, weil du da nicht als Einziger dann anfangen würdest als Nutzer, ne?
E-Mail ist, glaube ich, ein schlechtes Beispiel, ne, weil das ist wirklich der
Das ist wirklich die Definition eines kleinsten, gemeinsamen Nenners. Seit dreißig Jahren hat sich eigentlich ein E-Mail ja wirklich nicht äh irgendwas getan. Aber wenn du jetzt einen Messengerbereich äh mal anschaust, wo sicherlich der größte Druck
äh entsteht, ja, wo du also derzeit die stärksten Netzwerkeffekte zu beklagen hast, ist ja jetzt auch nicht so, dass es dort,
keine kleinen Anbieter gebe, wenn man jetzt mal so was wie Threema nimmt zum Beispiel, ja, was sich ja durchaus auch äh behaupten kann mit einem komplett eigenen Dienst
Würde man jetzt Riemer zu einer Interopeabilität äh auffordern mit anderen Diensten, müssten die ja dann sozusagen.
Also du müsstest ja quasi in so einem N zu N, Geflecht all deine Konzepte und Nutzeridentitäten äh übersetzen
können und dann auch noch ähm diensteübergreifend quasi den einheitliche Kryptographische Standards, um dann auch noch diese Brücke sicher zu machen, sicherzustellen. Also ich sehe da schon eine ganze Menge Schwierigkeiten.
Also ich würde, ich würde ja noch gerne ganz kurz eine Sache ergänzen. Also es.
Du hast einerseits recht, Tim, dass E-Mail ein sehr schlechtes Beispiel ist, weil es ähm oder ein sehr unschönes Beispiel ist, weil es eben ein im Prinzip.
Standard hat, an denen,
man, an denen ist der wie so ein, wie so ein Betonklotz am Bein ist, ne? Du musst irgendwie, du kannst deinen E-Mail-Server noch so schön konfigurieren ähm und irgendwie
am Ende musst du in der Lage sein, an irgendeinen äh E-Mail-Servern, eine E-Mail ausliefern zu können, der noch nicht mal SMTP, S spricht oder so was und dann machst du dir sehr viel wieder kaputt, ne.
Das ist ähm richtig. Und jetzt wäre die Frage,
was kann man regulatorisch machen, um irgendwie eben auch dieses, okay, du musst äh deinen Messenger interoperabel halten,
Ja, ähm dann sagen alle, alles klar, dann machen wir irgend so ein äh XMPPollback und ist mir doch egal, wie die Nachricht bei
bei bei Threema ankommt, wenn ich sie von Signal sende, ne? Aber vielleicht kannst du ja auch sagen, okay, wenn du eben wesentliche Funktionalitäten.
Musst du interoperabel halten. Das kann natürlich auch ein gleichzeitig ein Zwang sein, dass du dich eben nicht ausruhst. Du hättest ja.
Also der Unterschied ist ja hier, du hast es ja am Ende mit Plattformen zu tun, was etwas ist, was wir bei E-Mail noch nicht so in diesem Bereich hatten. Also wäre doch eigentlich das Ziel der Regulation,
eben die zu dahin zu zwingen, dass sie eben nicht sagen, wir machen nur diesen Minimalstand.
Minimalstandard und der Rest ist uns egal und da davon heben wir uns sehr viel ab, um zu sagen, guck mal hier, wie scheiß der Minimalstandard ist und guck mal, wie schön das alles blinkt bei WhatsApp.
Sondern dass man eben sagt, okay, du ihr seid dann auch gezwungen, euch auf einen diesen Minimalstandard eben regelmäßig sinnvoll.
Weiterzuentwickeln. Und gleichzeitig ist das ja ein bisschen so, dass.
Man hoffen könnte, dass in diesem Messenger und Plattformmarkt eine größere Mobilität der.
Kundinnen herrscht, als im Bereich äh von E-Mail und ja, leider Telefonanbietern.
Und und den daran gebundenen Nummern.
Wäre die Hoffnung, wir haben halt als als Vorbild im Moment ähm nur sowas wie wie Bahn, Schienen und und Telefonmarkt, weil das halt Felde sind, wo wirklich die EU,
so 'ne Art in der Operabilität oder so 'ne Zusammenschaltung letzten Endes durchgeführt hat und auch Vorgaben macht,
wie halt die damaligen ursprünglichen Monopolisten ähm den Markt öffnen müssen für Wettbewerber und äh denen Zugang gibt und ähm welche Standard es da geben muss und ähm.
Ihr habt natürlich Recht, das ist jetzt nicht so eins zu eins übertragbar, ähm auf Messenger Dienste oder soziale Netzwerke. Da müsste man sich in der Tat auf einen
Standard ähm einigen. Ich habe gehört, da sind welche in der Entwicklung auch schon, aber natürlich müssen die ambitioniert sein mit äh mit Verschlüsselung und ähm.
Ähm und unter Sicherheitsgesichtspunkten auch ähm
da abgesichert sein, ne? Und es wird auch nicht so sein, dass das im Gesetz diese dieser Standard festgelegt wird, sondern,
muss es dann letzten Endes nachgelagert. Äh vielleicht eine Regulierungsbehörde oder eine Aufsichtsbehörde geben, ähm die diesen Prozess äh voranbringt,
und man würde, glaube ich, auch ansetzen, vor allem bei den dominanten Unternehmen, das heißt ähm.
WhatsApp ist halt dominant, im Moment beim Messenger-Markt und ähm sozialen Netzwerken gibt's auch einige Dominante. Und ähm würde da,
ansetzen und ähm gucken, was gibt es schon an offenen Standards, die die entwickelt werden. Aber ich glaube, das ist alles eine Frage des Wie,
das ist überhaupt eine gute Sache, wäre, wenn man halt zwischen Messengern äh kommunizieren könnte. Ähm.
Das finde ich auf jeden Fall, zumal ja jeder selbst entscheiden kann, ähm will ich in Kontakt annehmen oder nicht. Ähm.
Im Grunde genommen jedem selbst überlassen und ich sehe das im Europäischen Parlament selber, wie problematisch das mit den Messengern ist, ähm.
Denn auf Ausschussreisen kommt dann manchmal der Vorschlag, lasst uns eine WhatsApp-Gruppe machen, sage ich, nein, ich benutze WhatsApp nicht
ähm dann äh streamer hat kaum jemand installiert, äh geschweige denn Riot, was was wir benutzen als Piraten, weil es halt dezentral auch ist und keine Identifizierung voraussetzt
Matrix-System
ähm und dann ist meistens der gemeinsame kleinste, gemeinsame Nennerssignal. Also das war ein großer Erfolg, dass wir es geschafft haben in den Verhandlungen über diese Verordnung
ähm alle im Verhandlungsteam dazu zu bekommen, eine gemeinsame Signalgruppe äh.
Ne? Das ist schon das höchste der Gefühle, aber es ist ein US-Anbieter, der ähm die Rufnummern verarbeitet und ähm du bist an äh an diesen Anbietern gekettet. Er ist nicht interoperabel und.
Da müssen wir echt besser werden.
Signal vielleicht tatsächlich sogar die Möglichkeit hätte, mit WhatsApp, Interoperabel zu werden. Ähm man muss natürlich hier an der Stelle auch.
Sich vor Augen führen. Manchmal ist es vielleicht auch sinnvoll, von regulatorischer Seite eben
hohe Sachen, hohe Ziele vorzugeben und dann die Technik eben über größere oder die Anbieter über größere Hürden springen zu lassen, um das zu erreichen. Leider passierte es wahrscheinlich in der Realität meistens nicht unbedingt so, ne, durch die.
Dann doch Nähe ähm zu der Wirtschaft, aber wir haben dann auch nochmal ein bisschen was zurückzumelden zu der.
E-Privacy Derovation. Ja, ich hatte da ja, wir haben das jetzt zum dritten Mal in Folge in der Sendung und zwar hatte ich da ähm,
Vorletzte Sendung drüber gesprochen. Da geht es also um im Prinzip, ich sag's mal ganz plump, Upload-Filter,
im Messenger. Ja, äh das das Gleiche Prinzip soll Anwendung finden in deinem.
Kommunikationsinhalt, um sicherzustellen, wenn man jetzt also um das jetzt mal in so ein Gesamtbild zu zu schieben mit der mit der Terrec äh ähm drängst du ja unter Umständen die Terroristinnen von.
Den Plattformen, jetzt haben, nutzen die auf einmal irgendwelche Privatnachrichten oder Privatkommunikationskanäle und jetzt musst du da auch noch versuchen, zu filtern. Spezifisch wurde hier eben diese Abweichung von,
der ähm E-Privacy-Richtlinie diskutiert.
Die dazu äh die im Prinzip sicherstellen soll, zu sagen, naja, pass mal auf, wenn du einen Filter implementierst.
Um hier in die Kommunikation einzu,
greifen, ja, wofür du ja automatisiert die Kommunikation scannst, dann ist das kein Verstoß gegen die e-Privacy-Richtlinie, was ist nämlich unter Umständen eigentlich gewesen wäre? So viel hatte ich auch in der letzten Sendung schon zusammengefasst, bei einigen.
Ist das ein bisschen aufgefasst worden, als hätte ich damit aussagen wollen, dass ich das deshalb nicht so, dass ich das nicht so schlimm finde. Äh natürlich ist das schlimm, wenn eine äh Privacy-Richtlinie aufgeweicht wird, noch dazu für so einen dann doch sehr.
Ähm komischen Zweck, dem ja auch wieder das Problem
Innet ist, dass er dann aufgeweicht wird für die nächsten Schritte, dass man nämlich sagt, ja wie, wir haben doch schon die Filterinfrastruktur und jetzt schicken die sich die ganze Zeit urheberrechtlich geschützte MP3 Dateien und
jetzt wollen wir diese Terrorfilter eben auch im Urheberrecht nutzen. Also genau das gleiche Problem. Und jetzt wurde ich nochmal korrigiert.
Ähm von ähm Ralf Bend, den du ja auch kennst, Patrick, ähm der eben sagt, na ja, das geht hier, da steht nicht, dass das nur.
Mit äh verschlüsselten Messengern oder so zu tun hat, sondern dass sich das im Prinzip dann wieder auch auf alles Mögliche ähm beziehen kann. Vielleicht kannst du uns diesen ganzen Themenbereich nochmal richtig erklären, bevor ich,
nochmal mich korrigieren lassen muss.
Also der große Unterschied zu den bisherigen Uploadfilterdebatten, sei es Urheberrecht, ähm sei es ähm terroristische Inhalte, besteht halt darin,
man will jetzt erstmals private Nachrichten filtern,
nicht, Inhalte, die veröffentlicht werden sollen, die ja im Grunde genommen sowieso jeder,
ähm ansehen und eventuell auch automatisch Spidern analysieren könnte, sondern diesmal soll zum ersten Mal ein ähm.
Ja im Grunde genommen private elektronische Post, sei es per Messenger, sei es ähm per E-Mail, äh aber auch ähm andere Kommunikationsräume, Chats.
Ähm sogar äh Gaming-Plattformen, wo man miteinander kommunizieren kann.
Können darunter fallen. Also im Grunde genommen die direkte private Kommunikation soll.
Soll das Fernmeldegeheimnis oder das Telekommunikationsgeheimnis äh aufgehoben werden. Die Idee von dem Telekommunikationsgeheimnis ist ja eigentlich, dass ähm.
Wenn ich miteinander telefoniere oder oder Briefe schreibe, dass ähm auf dem Weg nicht abgefangen werden darf, weder durch den Anbieter noch durch andere,
weil man im Grunde genommen gewährleisten will, dass ich über das Telefon so vertraulich sprechen kann, wie wenn die andere Person hier mit im Raum ist. Und ähm dass ich
genauso vertraulich schreiben kann wie wenn die wenn ich den Brief direkt übergeben würde. Das heißt,
Idee des Fernmeldegeheimnisses ist es, dieses Risiko auszuschalten, was auf dem Übertragungsweg entsteht
Und wenn man jetzt zum ersten Mal anfängt,
ähm private Nachrichten. Ich spreche mal im übertreibenden Sinne zu öffnen und zu durchsuchen. Das ist ja so, wie wenn die Post jetzt wieder anfangen würde,
ähm ja, quasi Briefe zu öffnen und nachzugucken, ob da vielleicht was Illegales drin ist. Und das ist für mich halt auch der Kern Kritikpunkt an diesem.
Ansehenen, dass dieser Generalverdacht, ja, dass man ähm quasi allen unterstellt, sie könnten was Illegales äh kommunizieren und deswegen gucke ich mal nach. Und die Mitte, die man dann einsetzt,
sind ja auch nicht nur ähm ich suche jetzt nach bekanntem, klassifiziertem Material, sondern zugelassen werden sollen ja auch,
KI-Filter, das heißt, die ähm nach neuem, noch unbekanntem Material suchen. Ähm
und zwar nicht nur Bilder und Videos, sondern es soll sogar Filter zum Einsatz kommen können, die den Text darauf hindurchsuchen.
Anbahnungsversuche, also irgendwie Erwachsene, die Kinder ansprechen, ja? Und ist natürlich klar, dass wenn man nach so ungenauen.
Kriterien irgendwie ähm sucht und filtert und künstliche Intelligenz einsetzt, dass da die äh Quote an falsch Positiven, also an Falschmeldungen
extrem hoch ist, dass auch die Mitarbeiter von den Unternehmen dann sehr viele private Nachrichten überprüfen und sehen werden
ähm auch durchaus private Bilder, private Videos, ähm die die überhaupt nichts angehen.
Und ähm es kann auch sein, dass sogar ähm erst die die Polizei letzten Endes merkte, oh das ist ja gar nicht strafbar bei uns. Und dass man dann eine Anzeige sozusagen äh bekommen hat,
Also ich mache mir nicht Sorgen um die, die wirklich die Netze missbrauchen, sondern ich mache mir Sorgen um die, die sie legal äh nutzen und ähm.
Die dann sozusagen zu Unrecht.
In solche Filter vereinen können. Und die zweite große Sorge ist natürlich, dass damit im Endeffekt ähm Verschlüsselung untergraben wird,
oder wenn man immer noch verschlüsseln will, wird als Alternative diskutiert, dass man im Gerät, im Endgerät selber filtert und letzten Endes eine Hintertüre einbaut.
Ja und und dann sind diese ganzen Messenger und over the Top Dienste letztendlich erstmal schlechter gestellt als die als Telefonie und Brief. Habe ich richtig verstanden, ne?
Ja genau, also dieses Gesetz, äh diese Ausnahme soll nur gelten für Nummern, Unabhängige Dienste.
Also die Dienste, die auf einer Telefonnummer aufsetzen, die sollen nicht da runterfallen. Das heißt, mithören lassen wollen sie offensichtlich noch nicht. Übrigens auch SMS würden dann nicht nicht drunter fallen, interessanterweise oder MMS, äh was ja gar keinen Sinn macht.
Wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Achso, weil die Nummer gebunden sind.
Es ist überhaupt witzig. Ich werde das mal nachfragen, ja.
Ja, die Definition lässt das im Prinzip ein bisschen offen, ne?
Ja, aber ich fürchte, es
ist so gemeint, dass die Messenger dann äh da davon erfasst sein sollen. Aber das Witzige ist ja, dass die EU-Kommission, die das jetzt vorschlägt und für sofort dringlich hält, dass die selbst ihren
Beamten die Nutzung von Signal empfiehlt, also eines Dienstes, der gerade nicht scannt
ähm die Nachrichten und da habe ich sie schon mal drauf angesprochen, wie glaubwürdig das eigentlich ist, ähm äh sowas hier zu fordern und gleichzeitig selbst einen Dienst äh,
nutzen, der sicher verschlüsselt.
Das ist bestimmt ein schöner Diskussionsvektor, ne? Den Leuten, ich meine
Messenger sind ja nun äh wirklich auch Dienste, die im Europaparlament, wie du ja schon angedeutet hast, äh kräftig zum Einsatz kommen und was sind das dann sozusagen bedeutet, ne, dass äh an der Stelle die Vertraulichkeit komplett äh.
Dahin ist.
Ja, du brauchst ja diese,
dient ja einerseits dem Schutz von privaten Geheimnissen und das kann ja auch eine öffentliche Dimension annehmen, wenn's zum Beispiel um hohe Amtsträger geht, die die sind ja erpressbar, wenn wir genau äh über ein Privatleben Bescheid weiß.
Es geht aber auch darum, dass Wirtschaftliche Geheimnisse ähm geschützt werden, weil ja auch,
Geschäftsverhandlung, meinetwegen über solche Dienste elektronisch stattfinden oder Geschäftsunterlagen, Know-How ausgetauscht wird. Und es geht natürlich letzten Endes auch um Staatsgeheimnisse, klar. Auch die Behörden selber,
brauchen 'ne sichere Infrastruktur und sämtliche Verschlüsselung die untergraben wird oder,
Türen, die eingebaut werden, eröffnen halt neue äh Sicherheitslücken.
Es ist nicht so, dass ich das jetzt nur als Verschwörungstheorie wieder darstellt, weil es gibt schon die Ankündigung der Europäischen Kommission, ähm
im Rahmen der Kindesmissbrauchsstrategie nächstes Jahr, also zwanzig einundzwanzig, noch mal einen umfangreichen Gesetzesvorschlag vorzulegen, der eben,
nicht nur freiwillige Maßnahmen erlaubt, sondern eben auch Verpflichtungen vorsehen wird. Das heißt, wenn hier jetzt,
im ersten Schritt die E-Privacy Richtlinie aufgeweicht wird, dass man darf.
Dann geschieht das im Zweifelsfall auch mit dem Gedanken, dass man diesen Konflikt aus dem Weg räumen muss, wenn man es nächstes Jahr verpflichtend machen möchte.
Ja korrekt, man muss vielleicht erstmal erklären, dass ähm bisher diese Messengerdienste nicht unter die Eprecy Richtlinie gefallen sind, sondern die hat im Grunde genommen den Datenschutz geregelt ähm.
Ja, bei, bei Telefonie, äh bei Mobiltelefonie, Internettelefonie, ja, so was, ähm hat bisher
ähm unter die E-Privacy-Richtlinie gefallen. Man hat aber jetzt äh vor einigen Jahren beschlossen, dass man eben auch die sogenannten Over the Top Dienste ähm darunter fassen will
und in Kraft treten soll diese Änderung im Dezember diesen Jahres. Das heißt, ab Dezember diesen Jahres wären dann eben auch Messenger, Anbieter und,
andere Kommunikationsanbieter verpflichtet, die Nachrichten ihrer Nutzer vertraulich zu behandeln und dürfen sie nicht mehr selbst,
Kenntnis nehmen und und auswerten. Und das hat jetzt offenbar ähm Facebook, äh Microsoft, Google und so weiter, haben das jetzt offenbar gemerkt und haben festgestellt, oh.
Dann könnten wir ja auch Nachrichten gar nicht mehr filtern, was wir im Moment machen, denn das muss man auch ganz klar sagen, Facebook Messenger.
Filtert schon heute Posts und Nachrichten auf solches illegale Material hin.
Wenn sie was finden oder ich glaube sogar automatisch,
werden dann äh Meldungen gemacht an eine amerikanische Kinderschutzorganisation. Das ist eine NGO. Äh interessanterweise die dann ähm,
die Meldung weiterverteilt an Strafverfolgungsbehörden ähm einschließlich Europa auch. Interessanterweise verfolgen die nur einen bestimmten Teil dieser Meldung, weil ein anderer Teil nicht strafbar ist, also ist auch interessant zu wissen,
aber ähm,
Du hast vollkommen recht, dass ähm diese Ausnahme, die jetzt hier im Eilverfahren durchgedrückt werden soll, die soll erstmal nur verhindern,
dass äh diese Vertraulichkeit äh für die Messengerdienste.
Gilt und dann eben so eine Filterung unterbindet. Das heißt, man will ermöglichen, dass das weitergemacht werden kann, was die Unternehmen
bisher schon machen, ähm macht dadurch aber auch die Tür auf für neue Unternehmen, die es bisher noch nicht machen, europäische Unternehmen, das ebenso gleich zu tun. Und du hast natürlich recht,
Nächstes Jahr ist schon angekündigt, soll dann die Filterpflicht kommen. Ja, also dann sollen dann sowohl die Kommunikationsanbieter, als auch,
die sozialen Medienplattformen, auf denen man öffentliche Inhalte veröffentlicht, sollen wirklich verpflichtet werden,
nach ähm solchen äh Kinderpornografischen Inhalten zu filtern und äh das zu melden. Also da wäre dann eben auch Signal dran.
Und da gibt's jetzt auch schon einen.
Entwurf für einen, Moment, jetzt muss ich gucken, dass der ist richtig übersetze, gibt es einen Textvorschlag,
der deutschen Ratspräsidentschaft für eine äh für die Novelle der E-Privacy-Verordnung und da findet sich das jetzt auch schon direkt drin. Das ist da der Artikel
sechs D processing of Elektronic Community Communication ja und da äh.
Ja, haben sich ist im Prinzip,
die gleichen, gleich lautende, gleiche Wörter wieder genau das gleiche drin und ja auch das wird eben ein ein wichtiger Kampf, weil es hier
ich ja schon versucht habe, mehrmals zu wiederholen, ähm,
um ein während der den Anfängen handelt, weil wir immer diese Aufweichungen von ähm Schutz gegen Überwachung, die Aufweichung.
Von Schutz gegen ähm Zensur an,
den Stellen bekommt, wo es am wo's am schwierigsten ist, dagegen zu argumentieren und uns dann
in dieser schrittweisen Aufweichung der Salamitaktik zehn Jahre später wiederfinden mit ja am Ende voll überwachten Messenger und keinen Möglichkeiten mehr
Ende zu Ende Verschlüsse zu kommunizieren, davon unbeachtet bleibt tatsächlich meinen ähm mein Argument, dass.
Diese Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte Kommunikation eben immer geben wird und die Frage ist,
nur für wen ist die zugänglich? Wir haben uns eigentlich in den letzten Jahren, weil im Prinzip irgendwie seit zwanzig, dreizehn, vierzehn,
freuen können, das Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte Kommunikation überhaupt
die Wirtschaft und Verbraucherinnen, um das mal so schön zu sagen, ähm zur Verfügung
gebracht wurde, der größte Durchbruch war da sicherlich, dass eben WhatsApp die Verschlüsselung von Signal implementiert hat. Ähm,
was dazu geführt hat, dass auf einmal vielen, ich glaube Milliardenkunden ähm.
Diese Technologie zur Verfügung stand, die vorher im Prinzip einfach nur ein paar Cracks,
zur Verfügung stand, die sich ein paar GPG-Keys gewürfelt haben oder die OTR äh über
XMP gesprochen haben aber sicherlich nicht äh irgendwie die Breite von Wirtschaft und äh Bevölkerung von diesem Schutz überhaupt
profitieren konnten. Und ähm was machen wir statt uns zu freuen, wird das jetzt wenige Jahre später wieder gezielt bekämpft.
Obwohl es, denke ich, sehr wenig Belege für.
Den hm ja den übermäßigen Missbrauch dieser Technologie gibt.
Im Vergleich, wenn man die aufwiegt durch den dann doch sehr starken und übermäßigen, eindeutigen Gewinn.
Durch diese Schutzmaßnahmen, insbesondere, wenn man sich mal hier Gedanken macht über Spionage, Tätigkeiten unserer.
Feinde und insbesondere unserer Freunde.
Es ist genau wie bei allen Freiheiten und Grundrechten und Schutzmaßnahmen, dass natürlich.
Freiräume sowohl für legitime und nützliche Zwecke genutzt werden und sehr viele Menschen davon profitieren,
aber dass es immer auch von einigen missbraucht wird für kriminelle Zwecke und dass man sich in der Situation halt entscheiden muss, ähm rechtfertigt ist dieser Missbrauch dann ähm dieses Recht, diese Freiheit, diesen Freiraum für alle,
komplett aufzugeben. Und da ist es halt bei der Verschlüsselung so, wie du sagst, ähm dass letzten Endes ähm ja alle darauf angewiesen sind, ähm,
miteinander zu kommunizieren, um ihre privaten geschäftlichen staatlichen Geheimnisse äh zu schützen. Ähm braucht so diese,
und funktionierende Verschlüsselung und da kann es auch keine Kompromisse geben. Trotzdem ist auf EU-Ebene im Moment Verschlüsselung massiv.
Und der Beschuss die EU-Regierung planen eine Erklärung.
Verschlüsselung unterwandern zu können, die wollen erreichen, dass ähm ja Anbieter verpflichtet werden zur,
Entschlüsselung auf auf Anordnung hin sozusagen. Ähm sie wollen natürlich weiterhin ähm,
Endgeräte ähm überwachen um Verschlüsselung im Endeffekt umgehen zu können. Es ist jetzt nicht geplant, Verschlüsselung selbst ähm zu verbieten oder,
wohl auch nicht geplant, dieses Verschlüsselungsverfahren unsicher zu machen, indem man weitere Empfänger hinzufügt, sowas ist ja schon mal äh angedacht worden von einigen Geheimdienstmitarbeitern.
Ähm das wohl noch nicht, aber trotzdem wird im Endeffekt die sichere ähm Kommunikation unterwandert und da ist es halt ganz wichtig, ähm der Öffentlichkeit zu erklären, warum das für legitime Zwecke,
gebraucht wird für Menschenrechtsverteidiger, die in China arbeiten zum Beispiel, ja, für Oppositionelle, ähm die das wirklich brauchen, deren Leben im Endeffekt von sicherer Kommunikation auch ab.
Und da brauchen wir viele Geschichten, da brauchen wir viele Beispiele,
um der Öffentlichkeit zu zeigen, das ist wichtig. Und übrigens auch für Kinder wichtig natürlich, sicher kommunizieren zu können und zu verhindern, dass äh wenn die sich untereinander Sachen zuschicken, dass das jemand abfangen kann, äh dass irgendwie jemand ihre.
Feststellen oder sie identifizieren kann. Das alles ist natürlich auch für Kinder wichtig und wenn man über Kinderschutz redet, gehört Verschlüsselung dazu, da gehört viel ähm.
Netzkompetenz dazu, um zu wissen, was sollte ich im Netz machen, welche Apps installiere ich besser nicht? Wie reagiere ich, wenn mich jemand anspricht und so weiter
ähm man müsste viel mehr im Bereich Prävention tun, denn es ist bekannt, dass Kindesmissbrauch vor allem im sozialen Nahbereich, ähm Familie,
Freunde, ähm ja, Bildung äh Kita, Schule, Sportvereine, fast alle missbrauchsfälle werden von bekannten Personen ja ähm
begangen. Das heißt, man müsste auf Prävention viel mehr setzen. Man müsste viel mehr Therapie äh Angebote machen. Da gibt's zu wenige Plätze. Es sind unterfinanziert im Moment. Und auch im Bereich der Strafverfolgung ist es ja so
dass die Polizei im Moment völlig überlastet ist mit der Auswertung von Datenträgern, die sie beschlagnahmt hat. Die kommen gar nicht da ähm hinterher. Und deswegen ist, glaube ich, überhaupt nicht der richtige Weg, hier noch den,
zu vergrößern. Gerade, wenn man ja wirklich in die Hintermänner eindringen will, in die Produzenten und nicht nur in die ähm
in die Konsumenten. Und ich glaube, um das zu machen, ist es wichtig, verdeckt zu ermitteln und sich in solche Netzwerke einzuschleusen und die dann hochgehen zu lassen. Äh da da bringt mir ein Filter nichts.
Ja, wo vielleicht auch äh ein Filter nichts bringt, aber trotzdem in der Planung äh ist, ist ähm.
Bei der Urheberrechtsreform,
wo wir ja nun schon jahrelang diese Auseinandersetzungen hatten und das ist ja auch schon äh erzählt. Julia Reders äh Pet Projekt war das im
Europaparlament. Am Ende ist es nicht so ausgegangen, wie sie sich das so vorgestellt hat. Jetzt haben wir halt diesen Beschluss und jetzt geht's an die
Umsetzung und ähm ja, dann hieß es ja auch eine ganze Weile lang nach ja, so auf Upload-Filter werden wir schon irgendwie noch verzichten äh äh können.
Danach sieht's aber jetzt offensichtlich nicht mehr aus, oder?
Ja, ich höre das ganz oft, dass Leute wirklich frustriert sind nach den Protesten gegen die Urheberrechtsreform, weil es ja ganz knapp um wenige Stimmen ähm nicht gereicht hat
Wir müssen daraus lernen, dass wir halt europäischer werden müssen. Es reicht nicht mehr, wenn man nur in Deutschland oder einigen anderen Ländern noch auf die Straße geht, sondern wir müssen dann es auch schaffen, die anderen Länder äh mitzunehmen und die Bewegung,
zu vernetzen und trotzdem haben wir viel erreicht,
zum Beispiel, dass das Europäische Parlament jetzt die Uploadfilter bei den terroristischen Inhalten ablehnt, ja? Ähm das haben wir immerhin schon erreicht. Und ähm außerdem ist es ja noch nicht gesagt, ob
diese Richtlinie bestehen bleibt, denn ihr wisst ja, dass ähm dem europäischen Gerichtshof eine Klage dagegen vorliegt,
Also gut möglich, ähm dass der diese Filterbestimmung noch kippt, aber einstweilen ist es tatsächlich so,
die soll umgesetzt werden, diese Richtlinie mitsamt Filterpflichten und ähm.
Die Idee war halt, dass dadurch ähm legale Inhalte zu schützen, ähm dass man sogenanntes Prefleging macht, das heißt,
dass man sagt, ähm ja, das ist ein Inhalt, den ihr vielleicht indiziert habt, aber der ähm ist allgemein nutzbar, da bestehen keine Rechte mehr oder ich zitiere ihnen nur, ähm ich habe ein Recht dazu, diesen Inhalt zu verwenden.
Und das soll jetzt wieder auf.
Jetzt genau, da gibt's einen neuen Referentenentwurf in dem das sozusagen nicht mehr vorgesehen ist.
Ja genau, nur noch in sehr eingeschränkt soll man dieses Pre-Flagging machen können. Und das Problem ist halt, wenn du erstmal rausgefiltert wirst, dann ähm
kann es ewig dauern, bis äh vielleicht deine Beschwerde Erfolg haben wird, dann ist vielleicht dein Inhalt gar nicht mehr relevant und überhaupt nicht mehr interessant.
Wenn dir wenn du ein Witz über Trump veröffentlichen willst und das dann schon kalter Kaffee ist und du hast auch keine Kontrolle darüber, was die dann wirklich entscheiden, die Plattform im Endeffekt ist das dann doch sehr willkürlich und weg,
zieht schon vor Gericht um seinen Richter durchzusetzen.
Ich will, genau das kann man vielleicht noch ganz kurz ähm zusammenfassen, also der ursprünglich weiß, du sagst einfach dein Häkchen hier Prefleck, äh.
Euch mal bitte keine Sorgen, ja? Ist Creative oder sonst was und in dem neuen Referentenentwurf ist es jetzt so, dass die Plattform verpflichtet werden, alle Inhalte während des Uploads.
In Echtzeit zu überprüfen? Echtzeit ne genau dieses Problem, was wir anfangs auch schon mal angesprochen hatten, äh das können nicht alle leisten,
Und ähm das treibt die dann eben in andere äh Fälle. Und jetzt äh oder in andere fallen. Und jetzt kommt der Punkt, wenn sie jetzt in Echtzeit erkennen, ja oder stimmt aber etwas nicht.
Oder da, da könnte aber irgendwie etwas sein, dann darfst du deinen, darfst du deinen Fleck setzen.
Oder eben den Uploadvorgang abbrechen.
Und das heißt natürlich äh du hast jetzt wiederum keinen Schutz vor fälschlichen Sperrungen, wie du ihn nämlich vorher hattest. Wenn du sagst, ich will gar nicht erst, dass der Filter kommt, sondern hier,
passiert äh die Filterung trotzdem und ähm ja, gleichzeitig, was hier noch äh.
Auch ein sehr großes Problem ist, die großen Plattformen sind nicht gezwungen, ihre Lösungen mit den kleineren Wettbewerbern zu teilen.
Das heißt, damit werden die Upload-Filter potentiell zu einer Markteintrittshürde. Und das ist äh übrigens in beiden Seiten schlecht, ne? Wenn die großen Plattformen gezwungen werden, ihre Technologie den anderen anzubieten, heißt das letztendlich, dass sie eine
Eine,
Informationen über die komplette Aktivität auf diesem anderen Netzwerk haben, der Konkurrenz, ja, wo irgendwelche Leute irgendwas hochladen, da kann dann Google jeden Upload dort mitfiltern und weiß, ach okay, solange dann nur
hundert Uploads pro Sekunde stattfinden, brauchen wir uns über die keine Gedanken zu machen und wenn man sieht, dass na, das steigt irgendwie an, kann man sagen, oh, Harfe, die müssen wir jetzt doch mal kaufen oder äh oder kaputt machen.
Und äh das willst du ja eigentlich nicht, ne? Dass dass jeder einzelne Upload deiner Plattform mit einem.
Sehr wahrscheinlich direkten Markt dominierenden Konkurrenten geteilt wird, der somit äh und der für dich dann noch die Zensur macht. Dann kannst du irgendwann echt sagen, okay, komm, dann mach mal hier äh dann brauchen wir gar nichts selber mehr zu bauen, wenn wir das alles.
Bei denen drin haben. Also hier und umgekehrt, ne, wenn die, wenn die das nicht machen, dann hast du das große Problem, der Markteintrittsbarriere. Also alle Barriere, also beides ist schlecht,
für die kleinen Plattformen und das Problem lässt sich nicht lösen und deswegen ist es so eine unsinnige Idee in, in, in diese Richtung.
Sich zu bewegen. Und wir sehen 'ne,
meine Güte, wie viele Jahre haben wir hier? Julia regelmäßig zu Gast und diskutieren wir über diese Upload-Filter und wir diskutieren das jetzt mit dir im Bereich des Terrorismus auch schon wieder und es wird es es hört einfach nicht auf, ne, dieser Hydra ähm.
Hätte man längst einfach mal ähm filtern müssen, gelingt uns aber nicht.
Das Problem mit dem mit dem neuen ähm Preflecking Mechanismus, der nur äh ähm zur Verfügung gestellt werden soll, wenn das beim Upload auffällt, ist natürlich auch das oft ähm erst nachträglich,
solche Inhalte gemeldet und in die Datenbank kommen. Und dann kannst du halt nicht mehr den Nutzer fragen, ist das vielleicht geschützter Inhalt? Das heißt, du würdest dann nachträglich plötzlich runterfallen und merkst das dann irgendwann, dass äh mein Video nicht mehr online ist.
Stimmt auch ein Problem an diesem Prozess. Habe ich noch gar nicht dran gedacht, dass du ähm dass dann dein Fleck nicht mehr setzen kannst, ja.
Ja, also das das erscheint unsinnig zu sein und es ist auch so ermüdend, ja, immer wieder natürlich sind das Detaildebatten und jedes Mal muss sich dann Julia hinsetzen, muss einen Artikel schreiben als die einzige, die das, ne, die das Thema so
in dieser Detailtiefe überhaupt verfolgt. Und auch die muss ja auch diese Änderung bemerken.
Und darüber nachdenken und sagen, nee, jetzt habt ihr wieder, ist wieder falsch. Ähm das ist wirklich ähm sehr ermüdend.
Gut, dass wir sie haben und dass sie wieder in Deutschland zurück ist.
Das auf jeden Fall.
Wir haben in Deutschland aber natürlich noch andere unsinnige Entscheidungen und da wollte ich mal noch ganz kurz ein bisschen was zu sagen. Es wurde ja jetzt hier schon seit längerer Zeit,
jetzt hier in Deutschland diskutiert wie man es denn schaffen könnte.
Ähm Huawei aus dem, aus den deutschen Mobilfunknetzen herauszuhalten.
Und dieser, diese Bemühungen haben sich intensiviert, so in den letzten Jahren und haben eine komische,
irgendwie komische Korrelationen mit den Wirtschaftskrieg Bemühungen zwischen den USA und China und.
Wird das gerne nochmal einmal ein bisschen aufrollen dieses Thema? Weil es jetzt das das Ergebnis zu geben scheint. Ähm.
Ja Huawei ist ein riesiger chinesischer Konzern, der vor einigen Jahren noch auch wegen größerer Qualitätsmängel ähm durchaus verlacht wurde.
Der ursprünglich sagen wir mal in dem Netzausbau in Deutschland eher so ein bisschen die Rolle gespielt hat.
Ähm ja, einerseits eben der günstigste zu sein und andererseits eben bei den europäischen Anbietern oder US-Anbietern, von denen man noch so kauft, ein bisschen die Preise zu drücken.
Es gehört zu den klaren Strategien eigentlich jedes europäisch oder jedes deutsche Mobilfunknetzanbieters, da weiß ich's, ich gehe davon aus, dass es in Europa nicht anders ist.
Eigentlich gehe ich davon aus, dass es weltweit nicht anders ist, im Prinzip ein Wender-Mix zu haben, also von mehreren Zulieferern, die Komponenten zu kaufen. Wenn man so ein äh Mobilfunknetz baut, um eben,
bei keinem in einer einseitigen Abhängigkeit zu sein und die jeweils gegenseitig in den in den Preisdiskussionen äh gegeneinander ausspielen zu können. Ähm.
Jetzt kommt also das Argument, dass von Huawei wollen wir nicht mehr haben. Huawei hat sich allerdings in den letzten,
Jahren, also ich wollte sagen, in den letzten zehn Jahren wahrscheinlich, zu nicht nur dem günstigsten.
Sondern auch zudem äh innovativsten äh Anbieter entwickelt. Das heißt, was Huawei dir heute,
fünf G-Technologie, fertig dahinstellen kann, das haben die anderen noch gar nicht.
Die haben also bei gleichem bei bei niedrigeren Preis sogar noch eine viel bessere und fortschrittlichere.
Komponenten im Angebot. Was dazu geführt hat, dass man im immer mehr auf diesen Anbieter setzt. So, jetzt wird das Argument geführt.
Ähm man dürfte das aus Sicherheitsgründen nicht tun, weil Huawei ja von den Chinesen kommt. Ich müsste dem vielleicht.
Dazu sagen es gibt bei keine.
Belegbaren Hinweise darauf, dass hier China irgendwo die,
Finger mit im Spiel hätte. Es wird immer gesagt, ja die können uns ja das dann dreht China uns den Mobilfunk ab. Ja, das ist eine äh eine äußerst ähm unwahrscheinliches Szenario, denn es ist ja nicht so, dass diese Komponenten.
Irgendwie
da stehen und am Internet hängen und China äh auf Befehl des Zentralkomitees, äh das jetzt ausschalten könnte oder so. Sondern es sind ja Kernnetzkomponenten
auf die es so ohne Weiteres keinen Zugriff gibt. Wenn man sich aber mal überlegt, wer hat denn darauf Zugriff? Es ist ja nicht so, dass du dir einen einen Radioaccess Network oder die Chorkomponenten irgendwie im Mediamarkt kaufst.
Und die dann dahin stellst, sondern die werden dir in das das gesamte Mobilfunknetz wird dir eigentlich gebaut von.
In der Regel sind das so GmbH und Co KG der Netzausrüster. Das sind irgendwelche deutschen Unternehmen oder deutschen ähm.
Ja GmbHs sind das glaube ich in der Regel, die dann eben auch immer so ihren Standort genau da haben, wo der Mobilfunknetz betreibt, wo die Mobilfunknetzbetreiber sind, Düsseldorf, Köln, Born, München oder so, ne? Und das.
Zufall, ne?
Die sind im Prinzip die sind dafür da, ne, dort also.
Nehme jetzt der deutsche Netzbetreiber kauft dann eben von der Huawei Deutschland GmbH äh die Dienstleistung, diese Geräte äh zu liefern.
In Betrieb zu nehmen und der der eigentliche.
Sicherheitskritischer Teil ist, dass die immer auch den Zugriff auf diese Netze haben, also.
Diese Diskussion geht am Thema vorbei, die sagen, du darfst nicht von Huawei kaufen, ähm dein eigentliches Problem ist aber, dass die Huawei Deutschland Leute,
sehr viel Kenntnis über dein Netz haben. Und zwar geht diese Kenntnis natürlich sehr weit über das hinaus, was sie selber dorthin geliefert haben, mit einer angeblichen Vektor, sondern dass sie im Prinzip wissen, wie dein ganzes Netz konfiguriert ist, weil sie das für dich gemacht haben. Weil sie dir natürlich auch die Lizenzen und die individuellen Anpassungen
verkauft und eingerichtet haben. Also, wenn man jetzt.
Vom Thema Vertrauen redet und von nichts anderem ist hier die Rede, denn bei den US-amerikanischen Zulieferern haben wir seit zwanzig, dreizehn, zwanzig, vierzehn war das die Belege, dass die Dinger mit einer kommen,
Da ist aber egal. Das sind ja unsere Freunde. Bei den Chinesen gibt es diese Belege nicht
Und deswegen haben sie jetzt auch in dieser Regelung gesagt, ja okay, also es muss hier Sicherheitsprüfungen geben und so. Und am Ende, am Ende hat die Regierung aber noch die Möglichkeit eines eine allgemeinen Vertrauensbeurteilung,
Ja, also wir nehmen, wir wir wir schreiben fest.
Harte harte Kriterien, Prüfungen, Sicherheitsanforderungen und so weiter.
Und am Ende nehmen wir nochmal so ein äh Regierungsvertrauensvotum mit dazu. Und außerdem sagen sie, äh wir wollen übrigens ungerne, dass Huawei die kritischen Komponenten liefert.
Bei den unkritischen ist das in Ordnung. So als ich das gelesen habe, habe ich mir gedacht, aha,
Also ich meine, Mobilfunknetz ist eine kritische Infrastruktur. Du kannst jetzt nicht sagen, hier ist der unkritische Teil der der kritischen Infrastruktur, das geht nicht. Ähm aber was du sehr gut machen kannst, ist zum Beispiel zu sagen, na die Kernkomponenten, die definieren wir als kritisch.
Und die äh Radio Excess Excess Network Komponenten.
Also die Antennen, Sendemasten und so, also die dort befindlichen und so weiter. Das ähm definieren wir als unkritisch.
Und wenn du das machst, dann hast du eine wunderschöne Situation, nämlich die, die du gerade in Deutschland hast, dass im Rahmen ohne steht und im Chor,
eher nicht.
Und ähm damit kannst du äh einen wunderschönen äh Trick machen, den auch schon die Briten gemacht haben. Das haben die Briten nämlich vor einem Jahr schon gemacht. Haben wir auch glaube ich hier berichtet. Die sind nämlich hingegangen und haben gesagt, ja also hier
Trump hat natürlich vollkommen recht, vollkommen recht, in unseren Chor,
nichts von Huawei, super, hier, Spitze. Und das ist genau der Zustand, den die ohnehin schon hatten und genau das passiert jetzt in Deutschland auch. Auf jeden Fall, wenn man jetzt mal sagt, äh,
dieses Vertrauensvotum da mit reinzubringen, ne? Wir haben keine harten Beweise für absichtliche Backdows in Huawei Produkten
gibt's einfach nicht. Bei den amerikanischen Produkten haben wir das, ja, also zweitausendvierzehn World ähm Veröffentlichung im Guardian und ich glaube, das wurde sogar.
Bei uns auf dem Kongress enthüllt in einem Vortrag diese Veröffentlichung. Also wird hier mit zweierlei Maß gemessen.
Und genau dieses zweierlei Maß äh möchte ich sagen, zeigt, dass es hier nicht eigentlich um etwas ganz anderes geht. Erstens
um die Erwägung zur digitalen Souveränität Europas und da würde ich mich sogar anschließen und sagen, es ist schlecht, wenn wir in Deutschland jetzt äh die zukünftigen Mobilfunknetze äh von,
China bauen lassen, weil wir dann in Europa die Kompetenz verlieren, so etwas noch zu tun. Und deswegen bin ich auch dafür, das nicht zu tun. Ja, aber bitte doch nicht mit einem
unsinnigen Argument dass nämlich hier eher den Eindruck macht man möchte man man wolle irgendwie Donald Trump ein,
ein Scheidenbeistand in seinem Handelskrieg leisten. Und ähm ja kritisch unkritisch,
halte ich eben für für völlig unsinnig. Es ist eine künstliche Unterscheidung
und wenn man sich ernsthaft über Vertrauen und kritisch und unkritisch Gedanken machen würde, dann müsste man sich überlegen, was mit diesen Unternehmen ist, die hier in Deutschland vor Ort sind und diese Integration machen. Und an deren
Vertrauenswürdigkeit hegt wiederum niemand einen Zweifel. Ja, was ich übrigens auch nicht tue, sind ja meine Kollegen. Ähm.
Aber vor dem Hintergrund muss man sich eben denken, die USA haben Deutschland mehrfach sogar gedroht,
sie keine geheimdienstlichen Erkenntnisse über Terroristen mehr mit Deutschland teilen würden, wenn Deutschland Huawei als Austatter für die 5G-Netze wählt. Ähm
und da muss man sich doch ernsthaft mal sagen, das sind unsere Freunde,
uns irgendwie damit erpressen, dass wir hier demnächst ungeschützt von von den Terroristen niedergemäht werden, weil sie uns nicht mehr die rechtswidrig erlangten,
Überwachungserkenntnisse mit uns teilen, wenn wir Geschäfte mit äh China machen. Also.
Kann sagen, aus wirtschaftlich wirtschaftspolitischen Erwägungen halte ich das für total sinnvoll, europäische Anbieter zu stärken.
Und diese jetzt schon überlegene und günstigere Konkurrenz aus China irgendwie am Markt eintritt, hier zu hindern, kann man total gerne machen, aber ähm.
Ich fänd's ganz schön, wenn man da einfach ehrlich wäre und nicht irgendwie diese Angst vor dem Chinese, vor der chinesischen Überwachung oder dem dem Abschalten des Mobilfunknetzes hier nähern würde. Das halte ich für eine eine.
Die Frage ist, wie wie setzen so eine europäische Wirtschaftsförderung an der Stelle durch, wenn die Unternehmen da im Prinzip freie Entscheidungsfähigkeit haben und sich im Zweifelsfall halt einfach für den billigeren Kram entscheiden.
Machen wir doch in anderen Bereichen auch, dass wir die subventionieren. Wir subventionieren doch auch die die europäische Landwirtschaft, obwohl die nicht konkurrenzfähig ist.
Ja, so ist aber billiger, ne? So, erste ist gleiche äh Ergebnis, aber muss das noch nicht mal subventionieren.
Ist nicht auch die Frage, dass ähm wenn wir über Vertrauenswürdigkeit um über Sicherheit reden, ähm was erwarten wir, welche Anforderungen haben wir an vertrauenswürdige Hardware und ähm IT.
Ne, also ähm.
Können wir nicht äh verlangen eine gewisse Transparenz äh vielleicht eine ähm externe Evaluierung ähm,
um äh solche Hintertüren auszuschließen und ähm wie schaffen wir es, selbst bei europäischen Unternehmen da.
Eine höhere Sicherheit und Vertrauenswürdigkeit in dem Bereich hinzubekommen.
Das wäre ja eine Diskussion, die ich liebend gerne führen würde. Ne, jetzt muss man natürlich sagen, es ist ja nicht so, als würden diese Komponenten nicht geprüft, ja. Ähm auch von den von den Mobilfunknetz äh Betreiberunternehmen.
Ähm aber die unterliegen natürlich auch, muss man ganz klar sagen, einem einer regelmäßigen Weiterentwicklung, ne, dass da typisches Mobilfunknetz macht
so sagen zweimal im Jahr ein Update mit Features, mit Konfigurationen und so weiter. Kann man übrigens auf unserer Webseite äh GSM Map auch sehr gut sehen, die wir da ja seit vor Jahren mal gebaut haben, wo man eben auch sieht, dass sich die Sicherheitskonfiguration dieser Netze durch.
Durch die Zeit auch eben verbessern und verändern. Aber ich finde halt äh also alle diese
rationalen Überlegungen, ne, über die Sicherheit von Mobilfunknetzen, über vielleicht Anforderungen an die Sicherheit. Von mir aus könnte man ja eine technische Richtlinie schreiben oder sonstwas, ne. Das ist hier völlig verloren,
diskutieren seit zwei Jahren gefühlt nur über dieses, wie kriegen wir Huawei aus unserem Netz raus, weil wir dem Chinesen nicht mehr vertrauen und das ist
finde ich halt einfach, ich find's ärgerlich, wenn so eine Debatte ähm ja in meinem Fachbereich geführt wird, ähm ohne.
Äh sinnvoll dort zu argumentieren, weil ich glaube, es ist eine Scheindebatte. Es mag sehr gut sein. Vielleicht führt Huawei echt wirklich Böses im Schilde und es kann auch, vielleicht schalten die uns morgen das das Netz ab.
Dann müssen wir's, dann können wir's endlich mit europäischen Herstellern bauen und vielleicht müssen wir hoffen.
Dass sie europäischen Hersteller das bis dahin noch können. Also wie gesagt, ich bin dem eigentlichen Ansinnen nicht notwendigerweise abgeneigt, ähm aber ich bin derart, wie diese Debatte hier geführt wird, äh das das finde ich enorm ärgerlich,
ähm dass eben nicht,
tatsächlich mal faktenbasiert oder technisch argumentiert wird und an anderer Stelle wird ja schon aus den fünf G Standards wieder die saubere äh Verschlüsselung rausdiskutiert und so, ne. Das ist ja nicht so, als hätten wir hier eine kompromisslose.
Sicherheits Komponente. Man hat ja eher fast den Eindruck, dass die merken, jo, so krass, wie wir diese Immobiliennetze überwachbar machen.
Vielleicht ganz gut, dass nicht mit den Chinesen zusammen zu machen.
Ich glaube, das ist, ja, das ist eigentlich die die Diskussion, die ich hier, wenn man mal ehrlich über diese Sache nachdenken würde, so, ne.
Wäre ja auch,
Vorschlag bei fünf G, dass man äh vielleicht überlegt, okay, wir können nicht ausschließen, dass bestimmte Komponenten äh komprimiert sind, wie kriegen wir dann das Netz äh oder die Übertragung so sicher hin, dass selbst wenn.
Promittiert ist, dass ähm wir dann trotzdem möglichst schützend die die Nachrichten, ne? Da.
Und da hat noch nie jemand Interesse dran.
Na das hat da hat sich noch keiner die Frage gestellt. Stattdessen, wenn mal jemand sagt, hier hätte ich eine kleine Technologie gebaut, wie man auch bei einem äh kompromittierten Mobilfunknetz eine Nachricht wahrscheinlich übermittelt kriegt, ja.
Stichwort Ende zu Ende verschlüsseter Messenger, dann sitzen sie sofort da und sagen, oh Moment mal, was hast du gemacht? Oh, da müssen wir aber kaputt machen. Lass uns mal, Moment, wir machen, wir überlegen uns mal ganz schnell, was hui ui ui ui ui, das geht aber in die ganz falsche Richtung hier, mein.
Vertrauenswürdig schon, aber jetzt nicht so ver.
Echt so also für für uns vertrauenswürdig. Was übrigens auch nicht vertrauenswürdig ist.
Ist Wahlsoftware.
In der Schweiz, ja, haben wir eine mit sehr großer Freude ein ein ähm Artikel gesehen, der ähm in der äh Republik erschienen ist, ähm äh ich glaube, ist nur online Magazin der Schweiz. Ähm eine.
Und zwar war der Titel Passwort Wahlen und ich dachte mir so, hör mal, Passwort Wahlen kenne ich doch irgendwo her. Das äh war doch in Deutschland ähm eines der Passwörter über die äh Martin gestolpert ist in Hessen.
Es stimmt nicht ganz, das Passwort war der Nutzername, war Wahlen und das Passwort war Wahlen Komma FDP für den zentralen Wahlergebnis FDP-Server im.
Ähm im Netz der Ecom einundzwanzig oder wie das Unternehmen hieß, jedenfalls damit ging
Dieser ganze PC Walk los mit diesem Passwort, wo wir ja dann eben die ganze Software auseinandergenommen haben, äh Torsten dann noch am Ende den Updatemechanismus kaputt gemacht hat und wir das Spiel so lange gespielt hatten, bis wir technisch,
eine Kette hat bis zur vollständigen äh Übernahme der Bundestagswahl zwanzig siebzehn und stellt sich raus.
Hier eben eine Recherche von Adrienne, Fichter, ähm.
Die also dann zeigt viele Kantone verwenden, veraltete oder angreifbare Software, um die Ergebnisse von Wahlen und Abstimmungen zu ermitteln. Der Bund sieht keinen Handlungsbedarf ähm aber immerhin wollen einige Unternehmen nun nachrüsten. Ähm,
Wir haben die Recherche verlinkt. Es wieder diese schönen.
Klassischen Beispiele, äh unterschiedliche Unternehmen, die hier äh betroffen sind, ähm weil äh ein paar Forscher sich hier mal länger mit mit mehreren dieser Softwares auseinandergesetzt haben. Allerdings auch.
Muss ich sagen, streckenweise die hier berichteten Schwachstellen ähm eher so.
Sagen wir mal, im im Bereich der Best Practices sind, ne, also was weiß ich, Fehlendes äh HSTS, veraltete Schlüssel.
Algorithmen und so, das sind ja eher so ein bisschen, ich sage mal so Standard-Pantest-Findings, ähm.
Nicht so einen äh wie uns äh PC-Wahl ermöglicht hat, aber es zeigt auch hier äh am Ende das Ganze ist eben genauso katastrophalem Zustand und es ist.
Dramatisch, dass sich da niemand drum kümmert.
Weißt du, woran ich das erinnert?
Da geht's ja quasi darum Wahlen zu hacken, also quasi das politische Personal zu zu beeinflussen im Zweifel, aber im Europäischen Parlament, jetzt gerade mit Covid-Neunzehn
hat man äh Remote-Voting eingeführt, ja, das heißt, ähm,
mehr abstimmen im im Raum, im Parlament selber, sondern ein Verfahren, wo irgendwie per E-Mail doch tatsächlich abgestimmt wird und zwar so, äh dass man ähm.
Sein Abstimmungsverhalten online einträgt, dann bekommt man äh so ein PDF äh generiert, was man ausdrücken, Unterschreiben, einscannen und per E-Mail zurückschicken soll, ja? Also ein grauselig ähm
Unsicheres äh Verfahren, wo du halt im Endeffekt auch nicht feststellen kannst.
Abgeordnete, die eigentlich gar nicht teilnehmen an der Abstimmung, ob jemand für die abstimmt und so vielleicht enge,
Abstimmungsergebnisse manipuliert. Das heißt, hier ist dann nicht mehr nur das politische Personal in Gefahr, die Zusammensetzung, ob die korrekt widergespiegelt wird, sondern konkrete politische Entscheidungen könnten,
manipuliert werden, wenn du dir Zugang zu digitalen Endgeräten verschaffst und damit auch zu dieser E-Mail Box.
Die verwendet wird, um ähm ja diese Wahlzettel zu verschicken. Ähm es soll sogar in den nächsten Monat.
Monaten ein astreines ähm elektronisches Wahlsystem eingeführt werden, wo dann gar nicht mehr mit Unterschrift, sondern,
quasi auf dem Server des Parlaments äh ja irgendwie elektronisch abstimmen und auszählen. Komplette Blackbox. Wir haben keine Ahnung, was das für eine,
Software ist sie wieder zusammengestrickt haben und wie man ähm überprüfen äh soll,
die Auswertung korrekt korrekt ist und auch da ist es natürlich wieder so, du kannst im Endeffekt nachgucken, wie deine eigene Stimme, wie meine eigene Stimme registriert worden ist, aber weiß ich denn.
Die Stimmen der anderen Abgeordneten so wahren wie die das wollten. Die gucken vielleicht nicht nach oder vielleicht haben sie gar nicht teilgenommen an der Abstimmung. Jemand anders hat ihren Zugang nur verwendet, dann fällt es wahrscheinlich gar nicht auf,
Also das ist eine Riesengefahr für das Vertrauen in die Demokratie. Und ich glaube, dass so Angreifer wie Russland zum Beispiel.
Durchaus die Mittel und das Interesse haben könnten, bestimmte Abstimmungen, gerade die knapp sind.
Tatsächlich zu manipulieren. Und sei es auch nur wissend, dass es zwar auffällt, aber sei es auch nur um das Vertrauen in die Demokratie in Europa zu erschüttern.
Man muss es noch nicht mal durchziehen. Es reicht ja einfach nur, dass diese Diskussion aufkommt und sozusagen äh in Zweifel zu stellen, ob bestimmte Ergebnisse überhaupt richtig waren,
dann ist ja der Schaden im Prinzip schon da,
in diesem Republika, über die Situation in der Schweiz, gibt's so eine schöne Zwischenüberschrift, die mich etwas äh stutzen ließ. Da ist nämlich davon die Rede, dass es sich um ein das hier ein unkontrolliertes vorliegt und ich grüblete schon die ganze Zeit, was was denn das jetzt schon wieder für eine Software ist
ich noch gar nicht kenne. Das ist jetzt hier irgendwie so ein Yakami aufgesetzt wurde und äh ja.
Ein Wordpress oder ein.
So, kennst du diesen Begriff?
Er muss sich googeln.
Nee, jetzt erstmal äh so aus dem Gefühl.
Mir sagt das auch nix so.
Jeder kann mitmachen, das ist offensichtlich.
Ah
Schweizer Formulierung und das ist doch auch was Schönes, weißt du?
Da kann dann einfach mal jeder mitmachen, damit wir irgendwie der der ganze Apparat sehr äh äh transparent und und alle äh ne, das wollten wir doch früher. Wollten die Piraten das nicht auch immer? Ich kann mich an so was erinnern
Ich habe hier noch so ein Wahlplakat von euch rumliegen, da steht das drauf, wenn auch nicht wortwörtlich.
Aber wenn wir gerade hier über äh die Abstimmungssituation ähm.
Reden im äh EU-Parlament. Das ist ja sowieso alles so ein bisschen komisch da bei euch, ne. Patrick, ihr sitzt da irgendwie mit so einem komischen Ding, mit Knöpfen, ne.
Also wenn ihr, wenn ihr da sein dürft.
Zustimmen ablehnen, enthalten hat jeweils einen Knopf.
Und den muss man dann, der muss gedrückt werden, ja.
Vor allem sehr schnell drücken, weil es gibt ja immer sehr viele
Abstimmungen, die in Rekordzeit absolviert werden sollen, weil die Abgeordnete möglichst schnell wieder nach Hause wollen. Und ähm da sagt dann der Präsident vorne ähm halt an, welche äh Abstimmung jetzt äh dran ist und manchmal verzögert sich das schon durch die Übersetzung und ähm dann hast du irgendwie nur,
was weiß ich, drei, vier Sekunden Zeit, um das Richtige zu drücken, da kann es schon mal zu Versehen kommen oder dass man äh nicht mitkommt, also
Ähm das ist schon sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Man muss jetzt mal unterscheiden. Sind das dann nur die öffentlichen Abstimmungen, wo dann am Ende auch die das Abstimmungsverhalten der einzelnen Abgeordneten öffentlich protokolliert wird? Oder sind das äh auch geheime Abstimmungen, die da Rohr stattfinden?
Also manchmal ist es so, dass einfach per Handzeichen abgestimmt wird, vor allem, wenn es ziemlich eindeutig ist, ähm wie das Ergebnis ist. Ähm manchmal ist es so, dass dann zur Kontrolle nochmal,
elektronisch abgestimmt wird, um ein genaues Ergebnis zu ermitteln. Und manchmal ist es so, dass eine Fraktion von vornherein beantragt,
Wir wollen, dass das eine namentliche Abstimmung ist, dass dann hinterher auch namentlich veröffentlicht wird, wer hat wie abgestimmt. Das ist aber nicht der Standard, sondern nur, wenn das einer.
Wirklich verlangt.
Aber wie ist es mit Geheimabstimmung? Die wird's doch auch geben.
Geheime Abstimmung gibt's auch, genau, dann benutzt du auch dieses ähm Druck äh System, ähm dann wird dir auch angezeigt, wie du abgestimmt hast, aber natürlich wird im Endeffekt nicht ähm veröffentlicht, wer wie abgestimmt hat.
Wahlen ist das zum Beispiel so, ne, wenn du Personen wallen.
Ja und ich meine, ist das schon mal in Zweifel gezogen worden?
Ja, ob das überhaupt gut ist, ist eine gute Frage. Also wir haben zum Beispiel als
die Kommissionspräsidentin Frau von der Leyen gewählt wurde, sehr klar gesagt, warum wir äh Zensursula keine Stimme äh schenken. Und leider haben sich alle Befürchtungen äh von damals inzwischen als begründet herausgestellt. Wir haben ja schon wieder den neuen
Zensursula-Gesetzentwurf jetzt äh vorliegen. Und sie hat am Anfang sehr viel Süßholz geraspelt, aber wir haben das natürlich durchschaut und gewusst, was eigentlich die,
Agenda dieser EU Kommission ist. Und tatsächlich ist es halt so, dass sie die Überwachungsagenda,
weiter vorantreiben, dass sie den Bereich Digitalisierung halt hauptsächlich aus Wirtschaftssicht begleiten, das heißt ähm Europa soll möglichst äh vorne und möglichst äh groß im Geschäft dabei sein.
Und.
Ja, okay, aber lass uns mal bei der, bei der Wahl bleiben, weil ich meine, äh im Prinzip, wir hatten ja diese Diskussion, also bei dem Wählen bleiben, meine ich.
Wir hatten ja diese Diskussion in Deutschland nun auch gehabt und das ist ja dann auch vom Verfassungsgericht beschlossen worden, dass im Prinzip die,
Anforderungen an eine Wahl sehr, sehr, sehr hoch sind und sind ja auch klar dargelegt worden, was ja im Prinzip den Einsatz von Waldcomputern in Deutschland.
Unmöglich macht, so weit man das derzeit.
Juristisch bewerten. Ne, weiß der Geier, was sich nochmal tut, aber ähm wäre das nicht eigentlich auch mal auf europäischer Ebene eine interessante Maßnahme.
Ja, schön wär's, wenn wir so ein Urteil auch äh auf europäischer Ebene hätten. Äh das Gegenteil ist aber der Fall. Ähm insbesondere ähm Island ist sehr weit
vorne und hat tatsächlich Evoting, ne? Du kannst also in Estland sowohl bei nationalen Wahlen als auch bei der Europawahl interessanterweise.
Ähm elektronisch über das Internet äh mit abstimmen und ähm.
Sehr fragwürdig, wie sicher diese Systeme sind. Natürlich alles ähm Black Box. Äh du kannst nicht dahinter blicken.
Du brauchst irgendwie so 'ne Bürger Wahltippkarte die da eingelesen werden soll aber,
fragwürdig, wie sicher das im Endeffekt ist. Und vor allem ist halt bei E-Woting das Problem, dass wenn du eine systematische Sicherheitslücke hast, dass sich das auf so viele Fälle dann anwenden lässt, dass du quasi in die ganze Welt drehen kannst.
Ja
tausendmal gesprochen, was mich mal interessieren würde, gibt's eigentlich aus deiner juristischen Perspektive in irgendeiner Form da eine Möglichkeit, aus dem Europaparlament heraus, das in Zweifel zu ziehen, also der dann sozusagen auch so prozessorale äh Fragen? Gibt's da irgendwelche Beschwerdemöglichkeiten, um da irgendwas
Richtung auf den Weg zu bringen oder müsste man klagen.
Genau, also du könntest halt Klaten gegen bestimmtes Wahlergebnis, wobei ich jetzt nicht glaube, dass du.
Gegen das Wahlergebnis, gegen die Methode meine ich.
Gegen die Wahlmethode selber. Ähm es wird genauso sein wie bei der Wahlcomputerentscheidung in Deutschland, da äh musstest du quasi.
Gegen die gegen das Wahlergebnis klagen um,
Methode zu kicken, ne? Also ähm die Methode als solche ist meistens nicht klagefähig.
Aber du könntest es tatsächlich versuchen, aber dann halt dementsprechenden Mitgliedsstaat ähm wo E-Voting zum Einsatz kommt. Denn das Problem ist, dass,
selbst die Europawahlen,
immer noch national geregelt sind. Es gibt auf EU-Ebene nur sehr rudimentäre Vorgaben, was die Europawahl angeht. Und ähm mit der neusten Änderung.
Soll jetzt eine eingeführt werden und nochmal ausdrücklich betont werden, dass die Mitgliedsstaaten die Möglichkeit zu äh E-Voting haben. Das heißt, sie geht eher in die entgegengesetzte Richtung, äh was.
Wäre es ja mal interessant, das direkt auf der EU-Parlamentsebene zu machen. Ich meine, du stimmst da geheim mit einem Computer ab.
So, du könntest ja das sozusagen als äh Parlamentarier anzweifeln, dass dieses Ergebnis korrekt zustande gekommen ist.
Ich habe da schon dran gedacht, ähm als dieses ähm als dieses Remote-Voting System da eingeführt wurde, dieses unsichere ähm E-Mail-Wahl,
ob man das mal angreifen und vielleicht vor Gericht ähm mal klären lassen kann, ob das überhaupt rechtmäßig ist
Also wir denken dadrüber nach. Im Moment machen wir es so, dass wir
versuchen das zu verhindern oder jedenfalls möglichst sicher zu designen. Also wir haben an den Parlamentspräsidenten geschrieben, dass ähm wenn er schon so eine Art Remote-Voting macht
dass man zum Beispiel eine sichere Authentifizierung braucht, um festzustellen, ist das wirklich der Abgeordnete, der da abstimmt und nicht äh seinen Mitarbeiter oder einen Hacker
könntest zum Beispiel das über ähm so eine Art ähm.
Ideen machen, wie das die Deutsche Post macht, Video-Edent, ja, also dass man irgendwie halt feststellen muss, wer Welt da eigentlich und wird da nicht nur die Unterschrift gefälscht,
Also da haben wir konkrete Vorschläge gemacht. Mein Kollege von den Tschechischen Piraten, der ja Vizepräsident des Parlaments ist und eine Zuständigkeit für die Parlaments-IT hat,
versucht jetzt, sich hinter dieses
System zu klemmen, was da jetzt geplant ist und ähm zu fragen, wie sicher ist das, ist das extern evaluiert worden, ist der Songscode äh öffentlich und so weiter. Also wir versuchen im Moment politisch da noch ähm Einfluss zu nehmen.
Aber weil du weil du ansprachst, das Thema ähm mitmachen und wo lässt sich ähm digitales halt wirklich sinnvoll nutzen im Parlamentsbetrieb
Ich habe jetzt ähm für einen Bericht zum Digital Services act einfach mal den Entwurf ins Netz gestellt und auf einer.
Plattform ähm die Möglichkeit gegeben, den zu kommentieren, up und down zu voten,
Verbesserungen vorzuschlagen. Also quasi bei der Erstellung von Texten. Das hat dem Text eigentlich sehr gut getan. Da gab's auch viel Input. Ist eine Möglichkeit.
Man könnte diese Petitionen machen, wo Leute mitzeichnen können ab einer bestimmten Schwelle, gibt's dann 'ne Anhörung.
Es gibt schon die europäische Bürgerinitiative wenn du ein Millionen Unterschriften sammelst und das kann eben dann auch digital per Internet passieren.
Muss die EU Kommission sich mit einem Thema befassen. Er ist sehr wenig, ist weit von einem echten Volksentscheid entfernt, aber ist halt auch eine Möglichkeit, ähm.
Digital sozusagen mitzubestimmen und ich würde mir wünschen, dass das Parlament.
Das ausbaut, also nicht im Bereich ähm politische Entscheidungen, da ist es zu unsicher, sondern in dem Bereich ähm mitgestalten ähm Feedback einsammeln, Transparenz.
Ist das hier dieser Diskuto äh.
Genau, ich hatte die Plattform genutzt, ja. Wir haben jetzt auch neu gestartet gestern ähm von der Fraktion her, ähm eine eine Website, die heißt ähm.
Also mein Inhalt, meine Rechte.
Und da haben wir einen Gesetzentwurf vorgestellt zur ähm Content Moderation, also zum Umgang mit Meldungen illegaler Inhalte.
Und da ist es auch wieder so, da kann man voten und da kann man auch konkrete Absätze ähm äh kommentieren, um diesen Gesetzentwurf zu verbessern.
Alles klar, dann nehmen wir diese beiden äh Beteiligungs.
Plattformen mal auch noch mit auf in die Shownotes. Ich würde jetzt langsam zum Ende der Sendung kommen, ich hätte noch ein Thema gehabt, aber das nehmen wir einfach mit in die nächste Sendung, das rennt nicht weg.
Und äh.
Ich werde dir erstmal herzlich danken, dass du uns so äh nochmal in Ruhe diese Themen näher gebracht hast, um die es geht. Wie gesagt, ich habe da auf der EU-Ebene immer so ein bisschen.
Schwierigkeiten, den Zugang so gut zu finden wie das in in anderen.
Bereichen, was weiß ich, in der Bundespolitik hier dann der Fall ist. Es scheint mir immer noch Underreporte zu sein, umso mehr freuen wir uns, wenn wir die Gelegenheit dazu haben.
Aus erster Hand die besten Erkenntnisse zu bekommen.
Ja, sehr gerne, ich verstehe das, das ist ein bürokratischer Moloch, selbst wir schaffen es kaum irgendwie, dass im Blick zu behalten, aber deswegen sehe ich halt auch meine Funktion ein bisschen darin, die Öffentlichkeit zu äh informieren und auch zu alarmieren, wenn was falsch läuft.
Ja, Patrick, vielen, vielen Dank, dass du hier zu uns in die Sendung gekommen bist. Und.
Ich muss auch noch kurz danken.
Zu danken, dann danke du nochmal.
Ja, ich danke Manuel, Steffen und Benjamin.
Super und ich danke einfach mal so irgendjemand. Allen.
Mach das, Tim. Bist du einfach auch dankbar.
Mache ich einfach. So, so, so bin ich, ja. Ich bin einfach so ein dankbarer Typ. Alles klar, das war's. Bis bald. Tschüss.
Ciao.